This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that provides free delivery set up and
mattress.
Christina [inaudible].
So
you think you're doing,
you think you're doing our son?
I think I'm doing Busta rhymes.
Our son sounds like lesser,
right?
Thanks.
Trash beets.
I don't know if I'm supposed to say cake.
Um,
what's up gene?
Where you at?
Well,
it was a crazy weekend,
first of all.
Amazing.
Thank you so much.
Everybody that came out,
uh,
had Jeff Tate with me.
We did a nine shows my God and started in Montclair.
We went to tits Berg.
We were in Cincy my hometown.
Then we went to Cleveland and we ended up in,
what's it called?
We ended up in,
uh,
DC water greenhouse tavern.
No,
we almost did,
but I ended up having such great food on the road because I make sure I,
I don't want to fall apart,
get all,
get all bart bodied.
So I,
uh,
I get chicken and fish and went to this place.
We've got food from the porch in Pittsburgh,
I think it's called porch.
Yeah.
Holy Shit,
man.
Yeah,
Pittsburgh is nice,
actually pretty to food was amazing and uh,
was a place to think an old town hall maybe in Cleveland that we went to.
I think we got food from there.
I don't know.
It was absolutely amazing.
But here's what's coming up.
Um,
Tampa's all sold out.
You can still go to the hard rock,
the Seminole hard rock and Hollywood,
Florida.
That's March 9th.
And that you can still get tickets to that.
That's at the big room at the casino there.
Then I go to Portland,
Maine on March 26 the 27th is sold out of the 26 has about a hundred tickets.
You can try to go to that.
Uh,
then red bank and long island.
Oh,
the late show in new haven has tickets.
The early shows sold out.
That's March 30th.
You can get tickets to the late show.
March 11,
or excuse me,
April 11th in Madison,
the late show,
April 12th in Milwaukee and the late show April 14th in Nashville,
Chicago sold APP.
But we added a show June 2nd June already,
homie.
I know,
but these are how the,
we added a show May 1st in Portland,
Oregon at the auditorium that's on sale and we added a fifth show at the more in
Seattle,
May 5th
the rest of the shows,
Thomson reuter.com/tour and a huge announcement in April where I announced the
second half of my tour the rest of the year.
And that's going to be like 25 more cities,
international dates.
You know a lot a lot lizards to pick up.
Yeah,
I know.
I got international lot lizards to pick up cheese homie.
Yeah,
it's going be real exciting.
Parlay into my dick in your mouth.
Wow.
All right,
cool.
Uh,
February 23rd it's actually this Saturday I'm in west Salaam Springs,
Oklahoma.
The Cherokee Casino February 23rd through March 2nd Madison.
Whisk come on Ya.
At the comedy club on State Wisconsin.
Does it shows are moving really fast and get your tickets.
That club,
by the way,
it's another one that's going to ruin you.
Yeah.
You,
you,
you're doing like all the best.
I'm doing that home run clubs this year.
I know.
Fuck Denver Mama was crazy.
Aren't you doing an acme to bro?
Yeah.
Acmes next April four through six mini show.
Ruined many apple tits at the acme.
Come on in club and then May 10th and 11th and Tempe at the Tempe Improv May
31st through June 1st flappers here in a sperm bank,
California.
And then I do Washington Dick Come,
uh,
June 20th through 22nd Improv at the,
I know the best heads.
Well,
you know why?
Cause I,
you know,
if to two little jeans,
I like to be around a lot,
so I'm only doing the,
but I mean that's the way it is.
Why not pick the best place?
I know the best clubs.
That's what we're doing this year.
Smart.
They know.
First Time we did some smart Christina p on line is where you can get ticket
lengths.
Follow me on the gram at the Christina being Christ.
I love the Graham.
I live on the ground or the Graham's good.
I don't post as much as I look at other people's that itching.
Yeah.
I love you.
I love you too.
I'm so excited for today.
Um,
there's a couple of things happening.
First of all,
we have,
um,
we,
so we did a segment last week,
um,
that we that with Kyle Kinane yeah.
So you'll see that things might look a little different cause the set changed.
If you're a viewer,
if you're a viewer,
you'll see changes.
If you just listen,
you won't really obviously notice much.
Um,
but Kyle was fantastic.
I can't believe it had been forever since we eat.
I definitely know it's so funny is that I haven't seen Kyle and the light of day
in about 15 years.
Yeah.
I've only ever seen him at night.
So it was when he walked in,
I didn't even recognize.
Yeah.
So you'll hear stuff that we talk about with him.
Um,
that was,
it's Kinda connected more with the Danny Brown episode,
which I don't know,
Gosh,
if you don't know,
if you've never,
if you're kind of just watching the show and you're getting into it now,
or you're listening for the first time and you're like,
what episode should I point people towards to,
you know,
get an idea of what the show is like.
Dude,
give them the Danny Brown episodes.
So great.
He's the best guest I think we've ever had.
Hands down that's almost 500 episodes with nothing but mostly comedians.
And he basically shits on,
I mean,
he,
that's how good he is.
He's so engaging.
And He,
and Annie's a mommy.
So they came in here and just excited.
Yeah.
So that was,
oh,
and I have not had been and I'm ready to try a prison burrito.
Yeah.
We got to do a prison brews.
The recipe he gave us.
I keep thinking about,
write it down.
I haven't committed to memory.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
I want to try it.
Also the episode I did with Dr Drew,
Dr drew after dark this week and it's a smash it.
Everybody loves it.
Yeah.
And you guys have to check it out.
Doctor drew after dark.
If you want to submit a question you can do so@doctordrewafterdarkatgmail.com.
That's d r d r e w after dark edge email,
phone number two (818) 253-1693.
Uh,
I would recommend that you kind of formulate your thoughts before you call and
you don't want to ramble way to write it down and the,
so this Friday mine will come.
That's right.
Oh I did one with him.
A lot of fun.
Yeah.
Uh,
basically we listened to some answer or questions from you guys.
we read some,
we talk about that we,
we talked about clips cause it's so fun to watch clips with him,
not just any clips.
Why am h yeah,
get into it.
The,
the cool guys or whoever we feature on this show,
we will go through it with doctor drew and he will give his insights into what
the fuck is going on.
So any tried is to get under the hood with Comedians.
Yes.
Which is,
I think the most fascinating thing is that he sits down with all of us maniacs
and figures out why we're so fucked up.
Yeah,
it's great.
So you want to subscribe to the doctor drew after dark podcasts as well as this
one by the way?
Yeah,
please subscribe
rate and review it on iTunes.
Yeah.
Uh,
if you watch on youtube and you subscribe to our youtube channel,
you will automatically get drew show.
It's fantastic.
So it comes out on Fridays on youtube and I believe a Friday at noon.
Yeah.
At 12:00 PM Fridays at noon is when video drops.
Yup.
And a audio drops Thursdays.
Okay.
Google play and iTunes and soon a lot of other places too.
Poor,
dark,
dreary.
I feel like he,
he just thinks we torture him.
It's so fun.
All right,
I'll let we have anyway.
So we have a Canadian segment from that is as part of this show.
And then Greg Fitzsimmons will be joining us soon
on.
Supposed to join him.
But she is,
I think in labor.
Oh,
boo.
Fucking hoo.
Their second child.
So women are fucking stupid.
I know.
Why don't you fucking go to your obligations?
You dumb bitch.
Yeah.
Teddy.
It birth like that's supposed to slow you down.
Um,
all right,
well let's start this show.
Let's get going to the bitch.
Leap.
Like call the cops.
What?
Coffee Cups?
Just kidding you.
You can just give you the cost is this week.
Don't bring it in.
Loving to this.
Go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Yeah,
I'm a cougar.
Wow.
Um,
I love you.
I miss you.
Haven't seen you all fucking week.
Oh,
you're fucking done.
And she sounds just like my mom.
She does kind of racks and memories.
You rest in peace.
I don't know.
So angry in life.
Didn't really fucking guns.
This fucking bitch can't fucking fuck you.
You're a mother fucker.
Day One that I met with and that was how you met my mom.
You're like,
my mom's kind of crazy.
Okay.
She's like,
Oh,
this fucking count in Bloomingdale's.
Say this shit to him.
I said,
fuck you.
You fucking bitch.
Yeah.
Whoa.
It was so crazy.
My mom,
Hey,
it was always confrontational with people.
She was deeply racist.
Almost as racist,
as Burp,
but that's not even really possible.
That's true.
Now I should always pick fights with people.
Yeah.
In the parking lot,
she would do something like that to this juice is not Sweden off your fucking
pants.
Yeah.
What is that?
It's called borderline personality disorder.
Mitch was crazy.
Bitch was cray cray and it's fucked up because you know back in the 70s and
eighties we didn't diagnose that kind of thing.
Yeah.
So my whole life I was like psalms wrong with Pico and people were like,
dude,
she's charming.
Yeah.
And then people would be like,
well,
that's just your mom.
You know?
You know Edith just rascal pants.
Sita.
She's just an immigrant.
You're like,
Nah,
there's some d deeper
cup people say like,
Oh,
you know there's real,
a spicy spirited.
Yeah.
That's another word for crazy.
When someone tells you your spirit is very animated personality.
Yeah.
Like bitches out of her fucking mind.
This lady that was in that clip,
man.
Yeah.
The setup here is that she is,
this lady is in a convenience store.
She bought apple juice like from the,
you know,
from the freezer,
right?
Like from the,
from
the free French.
And she's trying to,
Canada should sweet as fuck too.
She's like,
it's not sweet enough.
Super sweets.
All sugar.
She says it's expired and then,
well,
I'll let it unfold.
You know,
let them look at those tits.
Yeah.
Fires March 20th,
I'm sorry we can't help you.
There's no refunds.
[inaudible] call the company and complained to them,
but we're not replacing [inaudible]
company.
Company,
Call the cops.
She's doing her now.
She's doing her foreigners.
Swear this bitch just complaining about the carpet.
Oh,
she's not speaking to her language like curse at them and Armenian?
I don't think so.
I think she was saying the juice is bad.
You have no carpet here.
[inaudible]
I hate fat.
Fat.
So fat.
She's such a fatty and she's not wearing a supportive bra,
which is rule number one.
And when you got big sloppers,
you gotta buy the Bra,
hoist them titties up.
Hey,
I know.
Yeah.
Didn't you have to be cute?
She says she hates that pigment.
And Mexicans just dropping it on,
trusting all the real emotions come out.
One time I went,
I went to an all,
they have Mexican,
let's try,
this is my mother.
I went to an all girls Catholic school.
I was in the 90s.
I used to wear a Bandana on my hair.
I remember when my mother got,
it was not as kind of lesbian.
I,
I want to see that look.
Really.
I'll do it for your home Bandana.
Look.
Yeah.
So I,
I,
the nun called my left a note with my parents cause I was being hitchhiker.
You know,
you're like,
I don't like a lot lizard.
Yeah.
Um,
my mom got called into school cause I was talking a lot during class and being
saucy and my mom sees wearing this head scarf.
She's walking down the hallway,
by the way,
it's in the classrooms full of nuns,
nuns.
My mother walks in and she goes,
[inaudible] this fucking shit on your head.
You look like a fucking dyke.
And I was like,
um,
yeah.
And she ripped it off my head and the nuns were like,
oh,
okay,
this makes sense now.
Like no one,
Christine,
as a problem child,
they knew they did.
Everybody know they're like,
the mom is,
don't even call her in again.
And like after that,
I never got a no,
like sending home to your mom.
They're like,
we get it.
You're a good kid.
She said,
you look like a fucking dyke with this dykey thing.
And she hated lesbians.
She was very,
she hated.
She was like,
I don't know about lesbian doing to each other.
Maybe they licking each other's to death.
I don't know what the women do to other woman,
very race.
The homophobic is that homophobia wins against one.
She stayed licking each other's to death.
She had pluralize it wrong.
She was very spirited,
spirited lady.
You know your mom very spirited.
So speaking of Cray Cray,
yeah.
Can we talk about what we both been obsessed with?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Do you want to get into it or no?
One socio
dirty Tom.
Well let's,
let's set this up correctly.
So this is in a way a big deal.
Okay.
This
exclusive.
Well,
here's why.
Um,
as the audience knows for quite some time,
you have been accusing me of being a disturbed psychotic man who,
um,
loves blood and,
and,
and crime and criminals and all the crime shows are made for me,
my sick mind and a while ago I read this La Times piece,
you know about dirty John was a,
it was like a six or seven part profile that red like a,
like a thriller.
Like uh,
you know,
a book that you just can't put down,
right?
Like a crime story basically.
I'm sorry,
I'm drinking water right now.
So,
so,
uh,
I read it and it was just fascinating.
It was so like a while ago.
It was well researched and so well written.
Then that guy who wrote that,
who I wish I had his name right now started a podcast.
Yeah.
Dirt,
the dirty John podcast.
And listening to it,
um,
about the,
you know,
what he wrote and then they went even further and they,
they did the,
um,
this bravo mini series.
Um,
and this thing is exceptionally well done.
It stars a Eric Bana and what's her name?
Uh,
Britain.
No.
Katie.
Stan,
no smaller.
She's Great Britain,
Britain.
And so anyways,
to problem mini series.
So well done about the real story.
This is a real psychopath and guests who absolutely is obsessed with it.
Well,
if it isn't old psycho pants herself,
Christina,
I am.
I listen,
I,
you know me,
I've been resisting the urge to jump into your shows for about 14 years forever.
I never do it.
And for some reason,
what's the appeal here?
Dirty John got me hooked.
I am.
I am deep into the darkness with you.
Yeah,
fine.
We're,
we're finally sharing the shows.
Greg,
what?
What's his last name?
Do you know?
Oh,
oh,
sorry.
I thought you were telling me the name of the guy.
Anyway,
dirty John,
you got to see the show on Bravo.
Here's why I'm riveted.
Hey,
the guy's a total psychopath and he cons women,
but he's not just a con artist.
He's,
he's more than that.
Right.
When she say he's a master manipulator,
that's is a,
that's the name of the guy.
But if you look up,
like if you click on maybe like John Wick your pants,
isn't it?
Yeah,
that's who John Is.
But the guy that actually wrote the article and um,
you know,
did the podcasts like Craig something?
I,
yeah,
I know there's a podcast to where they go in depth on it.
Say who that guy is.
You can't read it Christopher.
No,
I can't.
Can you make it bigger buddy?
Oh,
Christopher.
Christopher mom.
Yes.
That's who it is offered.
Offered.
Yes.
That's who wrote the La Times article.
That's who started the,
the hood of this whole phenomenon.
And it is a phenomenal,
here's what I love about it.
So my mother remarried to a psychopath as well,
but he was,
he was a high,
he was nicer.
Uh,
he was just a criminal.
And,
uh,
this guy reminds me a little bit of my Stepdad the,
so that's the actual debate as the hook in the mouth because he reminds me a
little bit of watching that dynamic unfold between my mother and my Stepdad.
But I'm more obsessed with Deb,
the,
the woman's carrying raging to what said,
I fucking hate her so much.
So fucking much.
And I think what bothers me even more because she falls into the sheet.
So listen,
here's the story.
He gets,
he cons her or they get married within what five weeks story is that this guy is
a,
he's a lifelong pariah.
Okay.
Targets people,
sucks money,
life,
joy,
everything out of them.
And he does it in real life.
And in this story,
he does it to a a four times divorced but successful interior design.
This is what really happened.
He targets her,
she's pretty,
she's smart,
she's got her shit,
her shit,
their targets gets her hooks or Mary's or within eight weeks,
her adult children are like,
something's up with this fucking guy.
Cause he wears scrubs bay.
He's not really an anesthesiologist.
They find out.
They just kind of figure out that like this guy's full of lies and everybody
sees it.
But mom,
so that's what I,
that's what makes it,
because we can all relate to that.
Like how do you not see the,
because everyone is also had a friend who you're like,
you're dating this fucking piece of shit.
Yeah.
And they're like,
what?
And you know,
cause people will see what they want to see.
Totally.
And this guy is just such a piece of shit and it really wraps you in though.
And the story,
I don't want to give it away,
obviously.
I encourage you to read it.
I encourage you to listen to the podcasts.
And like I said,
that Bravo show,
if you're just like a good show,
man,
that is,
uh,
that show,
we'll get you.
That's really what it is.
Now,
here's my problem with Deb and here's why I'm hooked such an ass.
I'll tell you why.
So Deb is the woman that he gets,
right?
And by the way,
she plays her.
Really,
here's why Deb infuriates me is that yeah,
she's one of these people who sew and a sense just a deer in headlights,
big fucking doe-eyed led blind,
you know that the gentle,
so he's got the knife man,
he cure and she just talks that what the world is it bad place and I'm so
fucking envious of that being that naive.
Yes.
What a really boiled for me.
It's my rage that I will,
I've never had that privilege of being able to just be a dumb fuck in the world
and be that naive and innocent.
Like everything's great.
And the people around Deb protector and like,
you know what I'm saying?
Like where you just get to be a child your whole life.
And what kind of infuriates me about this too is the still whole through line.
They're like,
you're a victim.
Dab.
You're just a victim.
No,
you didn't do anything wrong.
You're a victim.
And it's like,
well there are so many flags with him.
And yes.
Okay.
The first time around.
Remember she,
she does leave him at one point when she finds everything out,
but then she goes back and then go,
bitch,
you're not a victim.
Like are you still,
do we still get to consider you a fucking victim if you know everything before
you keep going back
is like,
there's one thing where you're so naive that you're oblivious and unaware,
but when they start telling her and she understands that this guy is really good
that's laid out.
Yeah.
She's like,
yeah,
I know I'm dumb.
Oh,
it's,
yeah,
it's infuriating.
And she puts her children in danger.
That's also infuriating.
That may stop putting your fan and danger.
Yeah.
And I mean these lot lizards that I give them all the wrong information.
We talk about lot lizards.
I've been fascinated with this idea like,
so tell me about their life.
Like what,
so because I'm on a,
I'm the tour bus champ.
I take my bus across the country.
Um,
yeah,
I think the bang bus across the country.
Um,
and,
uh,
I've worked with a couple of drivers and they're really nice guys and,
but they have this life where,
you know,
they literally,
these do drive like a trucker would across the nation and he kind of,
you know,
it's a very specific type of living where they just get,
they get used to weird hours and weird living.
You don't,
you're not driving truck drivers.
Yeah.
Do they,
I mean the tour bus drivers have a little bit different than the truck drivers
will have.
A lot of times a cabin they can sleep in there,
in,
in the bus driving world and tour buses.
Some drivers will sleep in the bunks,
you know,
if it's like an arrangement in the master suite and he's not sleeping in the
bunk.
No,
no,
I get them hotel rooms.
Oh,
but I mean,
when you're not in the bus,
he sleeps in your bed.
You of course,
of course get grossed out by that.
And then,
no,
we don't.
No one shits on the,
on the bus.
He didn't keep brown bags.
It maybe,
but bags.
Is that what we,
basically,
we just,
you know,
we piss in each other's mouths and then we put it in the toilet.
No,
but so,
you know,
the,
this like really like kind of a traveler's life for real,
you know,
so you start asking him questions about sleep and cause I'm fascinated by that.
I'm like,
so when do you sleep?
Cause he'll drive us through the night,
you know?
And then we arrived somewhere and I'll get up,
I'm like,
Ooh,
I'm going to go get coffee.
He's like,
he's like,
Yep.
I'm like,
wait,
when do you sleep?
He's like,
I'll sleep this afternoon,
you know,
this afternoon.
I wish I was one of those people too.
I don't need to sleep.
Yeah.
And he'll sleep six,
seven,
eight hours,
but it'll be,
you know,
it'll be arriving to a,
it'll arrive,
we'll arrive somewhere and he'll sleep until like the show is over,
you know.
Okay.
So that's when he'd be I,
yeah,
but anyways,
we ask them about,
oh,
he told us.
So he told us who,
um,
so one day we got to the Pittsburgh venue and the Pittsburgh venue,
Carnegie Music Hall in Pittsburgh,
Super Old,
beautiful venue.
So old.
It's one of the only theaters that I've been to that doesn't have showers.
So I was like,
ah,
fuck,
because it's nice to get there.
You take your shower before the show.
So I was like,
I guess I'm have to use the bus showers.
Well,
the,
uh,
the bus shower,
the water,
because we're in the northeast was just so cold that it took like an hour to eat
and I was like,
it took too long.
So basically it's the first show in,
I don't know how long,
15 years that I haven't taken a shower before the show.
How stinky when you're nuts.
Pretty Stinky,
I guess my showered later,
of course all gaming,
but yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But anyways,
then we start asking what we're,
um,
so he told us,
he goes,
you know where the best showers are?
And then I was like,
where he goes,
truck stops.
And I was like,
what else?
He goes,
you have no idea.
They're like super
high,
like high pressure.
He's like nicer showers and you find him like five star hotel and I was like,
you gotta be shitting me.
He's like,
yeah.
And I go,
how much are they?
10 Bucks.
And I was like,
I want to take a truck stop shower too,
you know I want to get it.
Or you run the risk of getting stabbed.
You get,
you also wrote rafters and you also could like meet a cool guy.
Cool.
A lot less.
Yeah.
Well then the truck stop shower conversation led to what else happens at truck
stops.
I was like,
Hey,
do you,
are there really that he's like lot lizards.
And I go,
I like the phrase lot Liz lot lizard.
He was like,
Oh yeah,
they're there.
I go,
what happened to,
cause they knock on your door,
they knock on your door.
They'll just come up,
sneak through the,
and then you know they ask you if you want some.
And I go,
are they everywhere?
He goes,
not everywhere.
He's like California.
Sure has a few nice weather.
Sometimes it's a different arrangement.
Sometimes he said like,
you'll go like the driver.
Well like obviously like knows someone in the area.
You'll see like cars pulling in that they're clearly,
it's been a range,
like maybe beforehand.
Yeah.
Like the guy knows that this girl works in this area,
so lizard will show up and then uh,
have,
I was like,
oh,
what's that?
Like?
He's like,
I don't know about,
he doesn't know.
I'm like,
you
know about these lot lizards.
So innocent and you a dummy.
Yeah.
I wouldn't be in a lot lizard.
What I would like,
I mean,
I think a fun fantasy would be like a stranded girl,
you know?
It was like,
no,
I don't have any way to get,
get
dirty Dallas.
I'm stuck here.
I'm like,
Oh,
I'm going to Dallas.
Yeah,
come on over.
And then she gets on the bus.
I'm like,
no,
you got to pay the toll.
You know?
And then like what you do is he's really encouraging.
You're just wear out and you know,
what do you mean bang?
You know,
and the bang bus.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well you told me you guys take your turns on the,
that's what I'm saying.
Well,
I'm saying with this stranded girl is like,
she gets the business from me.
I give it to me,
I gave it to the opening act.
He runs through her.
Then the driver takes his turn and then we drop her off.
Nowhere close to that.
Wow.
I'm like Montana.
Good luck.
Yeah,
you shouldn't hitchhike.
You stupid bitch.
There wasn't going to go that far.
Well it's a lesson to learn.
That was a good lesson.
But you guys didn't tell me about a thing called hot bagging.
Yeah.
Well you can't make chocolate on the bus because can I guess on like
the really state of the art?
Um,
you're,
you're telling me like Brian Regan's bus.
Yeah,
you can shit on his shit.
On his boat.
He had a custom designed and right.
And then,
so his bus has like the special grinder and there's like coffee beans.
I swear.
He told me,
he goes,
what's the point of buying your own bus if you can't shit on it?
And he's kind of really good point.
I was like,
yeah,
of course.
But most of them,
most of them.
Here's the thing,
you can shit,
obviously it's a toilet can you can,
and in the end,
you know,
they'll tell you and you know,
if it's an emergency,
obviously don't think twice,
but some of them they're like,
you know,
there's just the ventilation of it.
All the shit is sitting on the bus with you and they're like,
it'll,
you know,
I haven't done it.
But they'll say,
they say it'll find its way into the events,
you know,
until they clean it out.
So yeah,
the hot bag,
you just,
you know,
you grab a bag from target or something and you just put that in there and then
you just get into that,
tie it up and then you can just leave it on the front seat.
You know,
a lot lizard,
a lot lizard is your payment.
Yeah.
Right.
Um,
I should into a wag bag.
I'm in Afghanistan.
Yeah.
That's how they do when you throw it into the fire
hot bag.
I had a member in Afghanistan,
a lot of people have been reaching out to us online and,
and elsewhere about,
you know,
the big news about Morton's.
Oh,
I don't,
pulling out getting their money back and like,
you know,
what are our steak house options essentially.
So,
uh,
we got a number of messages about it.
Um,
I can read you a few.
I'd like to hear it.
Go ahead.
Okay.
It says hello mothers.
I am the future CEO of outback steakhouse.
How do you know that there's this real,
and while I've never set foot in an outback steakhouse,
I plan on taking the business into my hands.
I have applied online to be the CEO.
God Damn,
I don't think he says he has no experience,
but he's confident in the next few weeks he'll get the call and as soon as he
gets the call he assigned,
he's prepared to give us $1 million check.
And on top of that,
all out backhoe locations will indeed give you 5% off your entire appetizer.
Even the Bloomin' onion.
Yes.
Ciao Kai.
Thanks Kai.
I really hope they hire USC CEO without any experience.
Well that one is obviously a joke,
honestly,
if this gets any better.
Um,
my name is nick.
I work for the marketing division of Texas roadhouse.
Hey,
that sounds good.
I was forwarded your email.
Uh,
we are a fine dining establishment,
are very active in our increasing brand awareness.
We were informed that your podcast,
which is a very select and unique market and to be honest,
that's exactly what we're looking for.
That's promising.
Great.
We need partners,
partners that know how to reach the people we don't always connect with,
you know,
the sort of people that aren't exactly watching CNN every day and reading the
morning newspaper.
Okay.
Below is a very specific description of our ideal target customer that we hope
to reach through new sponsorships.
A likes fine food,
including wet and dry age steak.
That's perfect.
Check.
Enjoys a good time with friends and a relaxing environment.
Okay.
Farts belches in public with no remorse.
This doesn't seem real anymore.
Possible suspect in active murder investigations.
Okay,
cool.
Guy Likes big sloppy knockers.
Yeah.
Not Bert.
Not.
If you think this sounds like any level of your loyal listeners and we encourage
you to reach out.
Uh,
we look forward to having you far in any of our restaurant.
Oh,
wait a minute.
And this is sign big Dick.
Nick.
Jeez.
All right.
So,
so far we have zero legitimate inquiries.
Um,
okay.
This one says a steakhouse in Korea town.
I love Korea town.
They have great meat there.
They own,
I own and run a beautiful steak house in Korea town.
Uh,
I would love to sponsor your podcasts.
All that we ask is you changed the name of the podcast,
the purpose of the show and everyone,
it appears in it.
If you're willing to try it out,
we'll donate $100 for every million viewers
through the goggles for gangsters foundation.
I mean,
this is just,
this is pathetic.
Such a bummer.
And the last one,
hey,
I worked at a steakhouse called cons.
I like the for three years Chinese.
So no problems with content,
but they are cheap as fuck.
Hit me back with some figures who I can take this further to try it out.
We've got Sushi and Hibachi.
Thanks.
Eli doesn't look like we have any sponsors.
Nope,
that's it.
I guess we're steakhouse sponsor free right now and we,
we're still free agents.
So if you know anybody,
your mom's podcast@gmail.com and make sure you throw the steak house in the
subject line.
And I do love your burbs.
Thank you.
They make me laugh every time.
Yeah.
Or you've been following,
by the way,
this a Jessie Smollett
sorry.
Have,
I mean I've heard about it.
I saw first I saw on it,
you know,
I do love the gram.
I saw the outpouring of I,
my favorite thing in the world is when people hop on board,
any of the social justice things like very quickly there's a shooting there,
the first person to supply and with all of you
fucking idiots.
Yeah.
Who gives a shit about your fucking die.
Put up a photo of a ribbon when that happens.
Thank you.
Fucking,
who cares?
Why are you doing that or no?
It helps him.
Nobody's ones,
right.
Those are my favorite.
And they do a picture of their,
like,
this is my partner.
I love her so much.
Do you love your partner?
I know cause I'm Tom his arm and I don't,
and we don't do that because like I just,
it's so fucking cheesy to be like the light of my life.
This is the one and only you're the inspiration and it's so sincere and earnest
like us.
I'm just embarrassed by it.
You're fucking queer,
you know?
It's just,
it's embarrassing.
I don't,
I don't like it.
It's more embarrassing when it's like a known person.
I know you're a regular person who's like,
here's the love of my life,
whatever.
It's different.
But like when the person with like celebrities do it,
followers is like,
yeah,
here's my lover.
Yeah.
Do Love them.
Look,
there's a picture showing how much I love them.
I think that's what I'm saying.
I don't think regular,
like everyday people,
that's normal.
But when you're a celebrity and you're like,
look at my spouse,
look how wonderful my life is.
Like bitch,
we get at your life and a,
I met Bastille Day.
Like I don't think he ever forgot that you out of raspberries.
Hate it.
Yeah.
Cause you and I obviously love each other,
but just like the gays,
the public display of it would make me vomit all over myself.
Weird.
Yeah.
So any who I was on the gram and I saw the outpouring.
That's how I know anything happens in the world as people on Instagram reporting
it.
Yeah.
And so Jesse smaller,
that's how you say he's an
or,
I mean this story is now enormous,
but so what happened was a few weeks ago,
he's an actor on empire,
right.
And uh,
he show's been on for a minute.
Yeah.
It's a wildly successful show.
He,
he's on the show news story came out that this dude was attacked at like two in
the morning,
allegedly,
allegedly attacked at like two in the morning.
Somebody put a noose around his neck,
beat them,
poured bleach on,
said racial homophobic slurs and then was like this Maggie country bitch.
Like,
so like an intense,
yeah,
the hate crime.
Right.
So everybody was like,
what the fuck?
But then like as the story developed,
it started to have peculiar details.
You know,
the whole thing is yeah,
it's just,
it's really disturbing and sad.
But so ends up with what we're at right now at least as the,
at the moment of recording this because this story will probably develop more
between now and when people even see or hear this,
you know,
but as of right now,
well we know for sure is that um,
like a,
a month or a few months ago,
he did receive a letter,
a threatening letter at the production offices and that he was resentful that
the letter and the threat didn't receive more attention.
Right.
It was like a homophobic racial letter cause he is openly gay and I guess it
probably is one of those things.
It was like a blurb maybe and then people didn't really talk about it much.
Well that upset him.
Hmm.
So what's allegedly happening right now is that when that,
when the attack happened,
you know,
obviously people are like we need to find the suspects.
They researched and all the cameras in the area and they did find two guys
walking around at that time.
So like these are the people of interest.
So then they eventually,
uh,
apprehended and arrested the people of interest.
It turns out there to Nigerian American brothers who go work out at the same gym
as him.
One of them has even appeared on an episode of empire extra number one.
Yeah.
And you know,
when the police were like,
we want to see your phone records because apparently he was on the phone with
his manager at the time of the attack.
He gave them a redacted version of his phone records word.
Um,
so things that started to kind of,
you know,
not really add up.
And then when they,
they spoke to those brothers,
uh,
they released them without charges and the investigation has shifted into
allegedly he,
Jesse perhaps having set up this attack as a ploy for the attention.
He felt like he deserved from the letter.
Interesting.
Which is highly disturbing,
highly disturbing.
And,
and,
and he did interviews.
Oh my God.
And he's like crying talking about what was said to him.
Like,
yeah.
Yeah.
Really.
He's an actor though.
He's an excellent,
it makes sense.
He was,
he was really a mother fucker ass crazy dude.
Well.
Okay,
mistake number one obviously is don't hire people.
You know,
like the guy at the gym,
you got to put an ad out,
you got to say,
piss on me,
beat me,
or you dude at the whole thing is a bad idea.
It's going to blow up in the terrible,
bad idea.
I mean also that you should see that these dudes that he hired to attack him.
Yeah.
I mean if these guys are allegedly attire,
if they actually attacked him,
he would fucking still be an ICU.
Oh really?
It's our Jack.
Really.
He must have been like,
look man,
I mean easy take it easy.
Like these guys are,
well,
you think even from a casting perspective,
you may want to cast like white big guys to do the hate crime as well.
Do it right.
You got two black eyes,
black you black motherfucker.
We're like,
wait a minute.
Yeah,
it didn't make sense.
Uh,
I heard a rumor that he was,
they,
he was getting fired from empire and he was doing this as a way to get
attention.
That,
I don't know.
It could be true,
but who knows?
Who knows what's at the root of this?
But that's crazy.
I mean,
it's also like,
it really is sad.
It's sad to,
somebody would orchestrate a fake thing like this.
Well,
and especially like actually get hurt in illicit sympathy from people that do
that to people dirty John Ash,
right.
Then like you go obviously like he's,
you know,
he is,
let's say a anti,
uh,
Trump,
right,
right.
But this actually makes you look worse because then you're,
you're creating this fake narrative of something like a,
of somebody who like a,
a Trump guy doing that to you,
but they didn't do that.
He's making it political.
Yeah.
But you know,
by the way,
if you do make it political,
you make it about anti Trump that you've rallied now the support of the
entertainment industry because everybody fucking hates Trump.
And
well,
what ends up happening is that now,
since he made that shit up,
then like a Trump supporter gets to go like,
oh,
this look what they're trying to paint me.
Sure.
Right.
This,
it's like it,
the whole thing backfires on him.
It's a,
it's a really,
obviously it's a super calculated,
poorly executed idea.
And if he wanted to do something like that,
should have talked to me first.
Man,
what would you have done differently?
I Dunno.
Um,
I probably wouldn't have done this.
Yeah.
Uh,
you mean like,
hey man,
we're going to have work out this fake hate crime.
Like,
so bizarre.
Now Bert would be a good guy to talk to.
He knows all about hate crimes.
I think we'll have him in soon and maybe we can run it by him.
I bet you he'll be like,
oh,
here's how you do this.
Oh,
good.
Good drunk.
First of all,
you got to get alcohol.
You don't feel so bad where you say all those words.
Speaking of a retarded,
I'm sorry.
I said I'm sorry.
Oh God.
What's going to happen?
Uh,
I apologize for any mentally challenge listeners that are funded by that.
Um,
did you hear that Karl Lagerfeld died?
Yeah.
The head.
Yup.
I sure did.
So I,
he was the head of Chanel White House of Chanel.
I don't know why he was.
Yeah.
So you know he's a designer,
he's very,
very famous fashion guy.
But what I love about him is I love anybody that has the audacity to have such a
stylized look.
Cause if you look at those teeth,
he is though that dude look like a bond villain for 50 years.
I know.
And all the every day to buy them all every day because all the obituaries when
I re read them,
they all say he is known for his ponytail and black sunglasses.
Like that is such a bold choice.
That collar though.
I remember that.
And fingerless gloves,
like who just walks around life wearing shades and fingerless leather gloves and
a ponytail and also it's not a timeless look.
Let's do wore this everyday for decades.
Right.
And it's not a timeless look.
No,
it's extremely eighties when he say,
I would also say it looks
like,
you know,
you see Accenture,
especially in New York,
you'll see [inaudible] eccentric,
older people walking around if this asshole.
Yeah.
Who's basically they're wearing,
yeah,
they're hot gear from the eighties or seventies and you're like,
you got an update.
That shit man.
It's been four years.
You can't do that.
Wait,
did you see as Trumpers?
Yeah.
By the way,
can go back to his tea fees.
I mean he had enough money to take care of me.
I spelled correctly.
No,
it's wrong.
It's Lagerfeld.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
Maybe.
Maybe it was longer and Feld getting l a.
D I thought.
Oh Age.
Oh yeah.
There's way more Lagerfeld look at that shit.
Look at that fucking guy to be that confident and self.
I don't know.
Is he though?
That's really an identity.
Dollar.
Here's the thing though.
I mean you're talking about like cut your like you couldn't wear that fucking
anywhere man.
People be like,
there's a crazy guy.
Yeah.
I mean like he gets away with it cause he's the designer.
You expect the designer to be.
But like,
I don't know.
And do you think at some point if I walked around I was like,
hey,
check out my tux.
Do you like it?
It'd be like,
you look like an asshole man.
I mean,
he's so fucking old toddler look at the collar.
But Tommy,
do you think the pony tail was real hair?
Cause he's old as she is 85 when he died,
probably was for a for a minute and no.
Yeah,
like a hair extension.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
Well he died.
What did he die of?
Just,
I don't know.
He said that collar finally choking out.
It's so ridiculous.
Ridiculous.
Well,
there's all these highly stylized people.
There's like Anna Wintour.
Like she's another one.
She's known for her,
Bob.
And then there's a Irish,
that's
him his last month.
What are you saying?
Yeah,
there's Anna Wintour.
She's known for this Bob Wright,
the bangs and the shit glasses.
But at least I feel like Anna Wintour could,
um,
you know,
somebody could dress like that.
Yeah.
I mean it's high fashion,
but you'd be like,
Oh yeah,
it's a fashionable late.
That guy,
no one could get away.
Nobody but him,
you know,
let me look.
She just looks like she's great.
She's like,
she's wealthy and knows fashion,
but type in Iris App app full I r.
You ever seen this Old Lady?
She's super famous,
like her wacky old lady.
Yeah,
she's cute.
She's adorable girl thing.
Like she's wearing like chunky jewelry and the crazy glasses like I'm working,
but that's what I'm talking about.
Identity in New York.
You would see this lady walking around and you'd be like,
I saw that this craziest,
most eccentric old lady today.
You know,
she's,
she's been rocking that shit for decades for sure.
I don't know.
With her it looks appealing.
Yeah.
It suits them.
But that's the thing is that Lagerfeld looks like,
he's like,
I've got to come.
Dungeon is how I do think he's letting you know he's got to come down.
Yeah.
It looks like it.
But how come some people can do this and some people can't.
Like if I put all this shit on me and have people laugh,
it's like you're at the stimulus in your essence.
Yeah.
Like you know that it looks appropriate on her.
When you look
at her,
you're like,
oh,
she,
she carries it like it,
it fits her.
Yeah.
It's because it's because she's not
trying to look like that.
Just is that even Lagerfeld that's like,
that's that guy.
So gay,
like he's so powerfully gay.
Yeah.
Gayness comes out and like fingerless leather gloves and the ponytail and the
Glacken.
What's that?
Oh,
that's not him.
No.
You missing look alike.
Who the fuck is that?
Looks so good.
Imitator.
You know,
it looks like a,
the guy that invented star wars,
what's his name?
George Lucas.
It's just like the gays.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
I dunno those chompers.
Yeah,
Bro.
You got to fix those.
I wonder if he was still smashing.
Of course.
Young of core hot model guys.
Oh,
of course.
Like last week.
Yes.
He's three,
like 19 year old guys were like,
you said you wanted to take pictures.
It's like,
I go,
but photos naked.
That's his game.
He's like,
would you like to take big picture?
Big Picture?
Cool.
Here I have a hot bag for you.
And they're like,
Mr Lagerfeld,
please.
His jam thought he's into all of that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
sure.
Uh,
uh,
fucking core hard fucking core for sure.
Yeah.
Oh,
I can't bring up the next hard fucking core guy.
Yeah,
we got some hardcore guys coming.
we got Kyle Kinane.
We got Greg Fitzsimmons.
It's going to be a good time.
I was a very good job.
Thanks.
Let's just read an email before we take our break here,
you know.
Sure.
I thought maybe you would want to check this out.
Uh,
here's an email.
It says my husband had the same problem for a month when we started dating.
He never had an orgasm during sex.
Oh,
Josh Potter,
Josh potters problem.
He would always have to jack off at the end of sex and at first I thought it was
something I was doing that was wrong.
Then I realize that when he was single,
he got comfortable jacking off a lot.
So I say to Josh,
when you get into relationship,
lay off the jacking off,
get it out of your comfort zone.
My husband can orgasm during sex now and anonymous mommy.
Wow,
that's cool.
I think maybe a,
it's pretty good advice.
What is a Josh?
Think of that
maintain Josh pattern.
You got to lay off the Gerkin Bro.
Stop being alone and having,
you know,
hardcore,
fun,
fun with yourself.
Uh,
I will say that I,
uh,
I have gone periods of time without jacking off like extended periods of time.
And do you think it had any relationship with the actual sex then?
No.
None.
No,
it doesn't do it.
It doesn't work because the cons of kind of seems,
it's sort of what they mean.
They're like,
oh don't jerk off,
don't look at porn,
makes more sensitivity and then you just faster or whatever.
But it doesn't,
you don't think so.
It hasn't helped.
I mean,
how long do I got to go years.
I don't know.
The concept of not pleasuring yourself,
it's never gone on it.
Well it seems like it's elementary,
you know [inaudible] one gene,
you nailed it.
Got me.
Probably set him up for that.
And when you've tried this in relationships,
because I've helped guy,
I'm dating someone,
I'm going to go for a couple of weeks without couple weeks.
Cause that not enough.
So you have,
you had a big buildup in there.
Like it's all backed up the pipe.
If I'm having regular sexual intercourse then you know,
I won't jerk off for,
you know,
cause I'll be like,
I'm going to have my dick inside something here in a couple of hours,
a vagina or a mouth,
you know.
Nice.
You guys.
Yeah.
Be whole and then it's still,
you still can't,
Huh?
Yeah.
We got to find you.
So you've been,
have any ladies reached out yet to help Josh View?
We'll have to see.
I mean,
through my travels I'll have to see if they're serious or not and their
endeavors.
Any local women on city of Los Angeles was,
if you'd like to make Josh pyre comes.
Yeah.
While I'm here,
you know,
since I do reside in La.
If you do also then sure,
yeah.
Reach out to me.
Other than that,
you know,
oh my God,
we,
we got like a few people messaged me and they were like,
I'm down to make Josh come.
And I was like,
are they in La County?
We need someone,
La,
look,
there was a,
I definitely,
oh,
there was somebody last week.
She was cute.
She was like,
uh,
I bet I could make Josh come.
You saw that one?
Yeah,
no,
I'm,
I'm compiling where you are in the,
in the country ladies and I am going to create a tour based off of where you
live and you absolutely,
yeah.
Have a make Josh calm tour and then you know,
the city that makes me come,
maybe I'll throw him a special.
So
I think it just goes without saying.
I mean this is,
this is the grossest idea we've ever had.
This is pretty gross.
You said greatest strong.
There was also,
um,
yeah,
there was that,
there was an adult industry person who said that.
Did you not see that one?
Didn't you get that one?
Oh yes,
yes,
yes.
Uh,
you know that one is,
uh,
in another state as well,
but you know,
it could be coming up here on the make Josh come tour,
dude.
That's definitely,
that's definitely an asterix.
Like you to follow up on that you were not friends.
Oh,
am I going to not follow up on it?
I mean,
do you know me at all?
Because she was like,
this message was like,
I work in the,
in the adult business.
And like,
I bet Josh could come inside of me.
I was like,
wow,
respond.
Yeah.
Hello.
I will.
I will hitchhike to that fucking city.
I don't need a show to do that.
Hold on.
How can girls get ahold of you?
What's the best way?
I'm on Twitter at Jay underscore potter or you can find me on Instagram at Josh
underscore potter.
Yup.
Or you could send an email to your mom's podcast@gmail.com and in the subject
line,
but steakhouse,
no,
no.
Make Josh Com.
Yes.
You can see,
you can see Josh Snyder
doing his own,
a headlining show with friends March 22nd at the Hollywood improv.
If you go to his Twitter page at j underscore potter,
his pinned tweet is a link to the show.
Yeah.
And if you come to that,
I'll make you come.
Oh my God.
Everyone.
Who Do you have?
Do you have any practicing now?
Somebody on the show with you?
Uh,
yeah.
Doug Mallory is going to be on the show.
My Buddy rob banks,
uh,
is going to be on the show and hosting.
It's going to be Maddie Hanson who's hilarious as well.
Oh yes.
Okay.
Well good luck coming and I hope you found it all over my face.
I hope you find a local la a smoke show.
Yeah.
If you're out there in la,
uh,
I could use some practice here in town.
You have to be good for you.
Come on out of the dugout and yeah.
Throw some hot heaters and my way.
Fuck it.
Oh,
I hope so.
One day there's Josh on tour
or Orange County adjacent,
maybe Riverside County.
So many babies.
I really appreciate that.
Um,
that message from a listener.
I think that's very thoughtful.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Um,
oh my God,
this is,
you want to read this one?
Yeah.
Here you go.
Long Ass fucking glasses.
I always forget my goddamn.
Yeah.
Oh,
Christ helps mom with conquering is the subject.
Hey gene.
So I was listening to an older podcast where mommy,
Tina was talking about eating her mom's edible underwear.
Yeah.
And it made me think of my own gross asked right with them just to see,
just to let you know,
I didn't eat the entire pair of underwear.
Uh,
my mother is,
we discussed was mentally ill.
Yeah.
She would show me about sex and she had a sex drawer that she would show me all
this stuff in and she'd be like,
this is edible and [inaudible] it tastes like Pena Colada.
And I was so young,
I was like,
what's Pina Colada like?
I didn't,
I,
I learned what a peanut Gelada was and what edible underwear it was all in one.
So it was disgusting.
So I tasted it.
I didn't eat the whole thing.
Anyway,
she says,
made me think of my own growth story with my mom.
When I was 18 I worked in a sex shop in Culver city and my mom was very much
privy to that information.
So one day while I was at work,
I seen my mother and my aunt at my store picking out items for their men.
My mom notices me and quickly tries to hide behind a small display table that
had our newest collection of vibrators.
As I clearly spot her and say,
hi mom.
My manager quickly turns and busts out laughing saying how cool it was that my
mom was a customer.
We worked on commission at my store,
so my coworker who was assisting my mom at the time allows me to ring her and my
aunt up gross,
which is something I did not want to do in cabs but couldn't say no.
So I helped my mom purchased a vibrating cock ring,
five samples of Lube and over the counter hormone pills for her and her BF.
Mind you,
I had barely graduated high school and was mortified to know what my mom was
doing in the bedroom.
This is just one thing I knew too much about in comparison to all the other
nasty ass thing she had asked me in regards to her sex life.
Keep it high and tight y'all and no,
I wouldn't marry my mom from Danny.
That's intense
enough lube.
You know how I fuck.
That's how my mom was though.
And My mother would show me her douche bag,
like the old school Douche,
like the bulb and the black thing and the orange box.
And she always tell me,
men,
Bill,
not like woman,
this thing keep,
that's true.
You'll have to vie showed a vagina and you cannot wear underwear to bed.
You have to let your vagina breathe.
Your mom nailed some things.
She does know that men don't like women was the pussies,
but who likes anybody with stinky pussies?
It's not.
There's a few out there.
It's true.
Maybe Jewish potter deal likes to keep pussies.
Nah,
I'm one of those.
Uh,
those Weirdo is clean.
I'm in to having a clean one too.
That was pretty wild.
Here's a,
I don't want to know anything about how much my parents though course.
How much do you think your parents thought?
I've gotten a few over the years.
Almost 40 of my dad.
You know,
we've had him on the show where he's like,
I like a full Bush.
I like big tits to even that,
I'm like,
it still feels like a,
it doesn't feel real.
It feels like it's a character saying it and you know,
but like to think about it,
we'll send me so nasty.
Well it's inappropriate your children,
but can I tell you what I always think about Tommy when I'm,
I thought about it even last night as I was walking around in our bedroom,
I wasn't wearing a bra under my shirt.
And I thought about how when your mom came to visit us about two years ago,
remember I took her Bra shopping to get her the right size for her.
That does.
Because they're low hanging fruit,
right?
Yeah.
And your father was very upset with me that I actually wanted them.
Supportive Bra.
Yeah.
And,
and I gave your mom to like a house Brah cause I wear like around the house
without an underwire,
kind of a loose,
just something to hold them.
And he said that he doesn't like her wearing that.
Even the,
he likes it low and loose and jiggly right
around the house.
It's so disturbing.
I don't want to think about it.
I know.
Stop talking.
It's so gross.
Okay.
What do you prefer though?
Would you want mine to be hangers low or too,
I like you.
I mean,
I like just you to be comfortable and however your breast hangs works for me.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You don't have to not be like,
Ahh,
I would love to wear a bra.
My husband's Dick gets,
my husband gets real upset if I yeah.
He runs and makes your dad's Dong hard.
Alright,
so we've got this other email.
It says,
Hey,
alert.
Am I the only one that's going to point out how the hardrock nick looks like
Tom,
who took a left turn earlier in life.
Carson.
Um,
okay.
First of all,
first of all,
let me address that too,
cause that's some more retarded shit.
I'm going to get
so profiled hard rock nick,
last week.
It was pretty much,
it was,
it blew up in a,
in a lot of ways.
Um,
sky's got real,
ended up opening the comments on his,
uh,
Instagram.
They were closed before.
That's brilliant.
Whoever did that.
That's Kyle Johnson.
Oh my goodness.
But look,
if you go to his Instagram,
he had to close comments.
Now they're open.
Yeah.
Just like Mcdonald's.
Uh,
Garth.
They went crazy on it.
Um,
so here's what I want to tell you though.
We didn't know a lot about and we just saw a cool guy and uh,
we,
we profiled them,
you know,
we just like played clips and,
and uh,
anyways,
we when it,
it got a huge reaction Pete.
Like they bombarded at his comments,
he ended up deleting and blocking a lot of them to our listeners.
You know who did that too?
Like,
um,
like we didn't even help with it,
but Morton's did that.
But anyway,
I didn't know anything about the guy.
Mommy army.
Let me just say this,
I didn't know anything about the guy.
And then like we were sent,
a lot of people sent us to this Twitter handle.
I'm not going to read this whole thing,
but you can read it yourself at B as in boy,
d as in dog,
n as in Nancy,
deep B d n deep.
That dude has a thread on him that is disturb.
I mean,
you know,
it's just the guys.
Three Jon's style is dirty.
John's style.
There's another guy who I guess used to be friends with him on on Instagram.
That also has a thing going on.
But anyways,
that Twitter thread is pretty,
can I see the picture of Tom Again as this guy?
It's my
favorite.
The picture of him holding the mic from him.
Which,
which score is that?
What?
What's special is that Tom?
That's from disgraceful.
Yeah,
I still fuck a lot.
Sorry to yell at,
you know,
and I kept thinking about this way.
Retarded man.
I kept thinking about how he used to go.
He used to have two Amazon packages a week and now it's down there.
It's a crazy line.
Wait,
how do you even conceive?
Like how do you want to think is a migraine?
No,
I dunno.
And it,
how was that a bragging thing that you went from two down to one?
Like shouldn't you be upping your Amazon prime deliveries if you're a baller,
you're trying to figure this out.
I am trying,
I'm trying.
I know that makes no sense.
Enigma and a new guys,
just so you know.
Yeah.
You'll hear when we have Kyle and it's a a separate time.
So it's like,
it's still kind of fresh to us.
Right.
So we're excited.
Yeah.
But now it's like what's going on?
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Hold on.
Anyways,
we uh,
we should be back momentarily with Fitzsimmons.
Great.
We'll be back to getting physical after this quick break.
And we are back with one of my absolute favorite comedians in the world.
Absolutely hilarious.
Podcaster and comedian and writer Greg Fitzsimmons.
Oh,
I'll come back.
Boy do I like that intro.
That means nice to hear.
It's so true.
You're one of the best comedians in the world.
One of my absolute favorites to watch.
Thankfully you're here without that dumb broad you were going to bring,
um,
with the dumb,
what broad doesn't even know that kind of talk.
And that's how sweet Greg is.
Nice guy.
No,
I was like,
well,
we know you are.
You have a isn't a new podcast with her.
Yeah,
we've done about a dozen episodes.
Childish,
Alison Rosen.
She would've been here.
But as we all know,
lot of women out there fully fucking full of shit and there's stupid.
Right.
So,
well that's why you can't hire them because they're going to go get fucking
knocked up.
Yes.
Works and like this would've been a cool place to show the dynamic.
That's right.
Two of you.
But now you know I'll have it with you.
I'll pretend that you're hurt.
Okay,
I'll do that.
Here is a big news about her as you know,
she's going to have the baby literally by the time his hair is,
she may have had it.
Yup.
And she's been constipated.
Really bad.
Real where she's like using her finger to work it out.
Wow.
Very hard.
Does that.
Yeah.
And so yesterday she took ready for this?
A nine pound shit.
Cause you know they,
they way you constantly and she lost nine pounds.
Wow.
She took a laxative and finally let it out.
It left like a week.
Wow.
I wish we could've seen those logs.
I mean that's going to be bigger than the baby.
How much is the baby?
Is the baby
that is the baby baby weight.
She talked about,
what,
did she say,
what she saw in the bowl or no,
no,
she didn't get into the details.
She's told me recently it's been all pebbles.
It happens,
you know,
the,
the hormonal shifts plus your intestines are all scrambled.
So yeah,
you have to be very vigilant about browning.
And I was very vigilant with my browns every day.
A lot of fiber.
You had to get it in there.
Right.
You know,
if she was that cost,
but it may be dehydrated too.
I think the baby can draw the liquid steel that liquid from you,
the executive,
everything.
They're inside your body taking your shit.
Yeah,
no,
I know fucking babies.
Um,
before we begin though,
I have a,
why am I,
where are we told about this or not?
I is a surprise.
To me.
It's get the exclusive out of the way now and for you,
while we're waiting for Greg to arrive,
I saw you need this.
I need some fucking music is a big deal.
I saw Josh Potter.
Yeah.
Eat something.
Whoa.
Josh is a comedian who also works with us.
He's just him.
He's hilarious comic.
He is a human cockroach.
He,
he's like 40 degrees is hot.
I don't eat,
I sleep from 3:00 PM to eight.
I can't come with a woman like all can't come with a woman.
He can only come if he takes over and strokes it himself,
but he can't actually finish.
So you can just,
he can just bang for hours and just be like,
sorry.
Oh.
So he can make love to a woman.
He just can't come play.
Have you ever faked it because you were too drunk to pop a that's a good
question.
I did once.
You did.
Yeah.
And I took the condom off real quick and threw it out before she could see was
empty.
Yeah.
Wow.
What a life you've had faked an orgasm.
I was a man now see,
but we can feel,
but if you're both drunk,
she probably couldn't follow the condom on.
Now before we move on,
Josh ate a twinkie twinkie,
so we still still a cockroach is going to live long full of nasty shit.
And so I feel like I faked a,
coming with an ugly girl was like,
I just was like,
oh I want this to be over.
So I was like,
oh you do.
Cause I know about the trolls that you've parked.
You've told me
to all the trolls
when I fucked my friend's and yeah,
that was bad day.
Whoa.
I was 21 she was in her 40 or so,
like now that's crazy.
20 some year age gap.
And I was hammered,
I mean really hammered.
All I remember was that,
you know,
I definitely didn't finish.
I don't think I pretended I was just,
I just remember
dude waking up right and waking up and I'm looking out a window because I'm in
bed and I'm looking out this window like where am I?
You know,
like totally coming to this is the next morning.
Yeah,
where the fuck am I?
It's like nine o'clock in the morning.
I was like,
oh so hung over and then I just feel an arm around me.
It's like a movie.
And I'm like,
what?
And she's like,
hey baby,
cause in the morning and I turn and it looked like bill Belicheck in a wig.
I was like,
oh,
and then she was like,
I'm going to take a shower.
I'll see,
and I was like,
oh,
I'm going to sprint out of here.
Yeah,
my clothes is all over the house.
I get dressed and I was like about to walk out the front door.
I realized not only did I not drive here,
I don't know where I am,
so I just had to wait downstairs,
like kind of pacing nervous.
This is before Uber.
Oh yeah,
it's,
I mean it was 20 so it'd be for me too.
Yeah,
yeah.
Then I see on the frigerator the report cards,
seventh grade
and then you,
the best part is that when I finally,
she drops me off and I was like,
oh my God,
my friend calls me.
He's like,
did you fuck my aunt?
I was like,
I think so.
He's like,
oh no man.
That's some real logos and your past real gnarly bitches in your past.
Now if I was here on a regular with with her on a regular basis,
I'd be like Josh,
I couldn't come either.
I would just be like,
I don't know what it is but I can't finish.
I had this SAP dammit.
I had this woman one time and he was a Gig,
you know,
I was a Boston comic and we would go out and you know,
me and Rogan and burr and all the Dane Cook we were doing,
why writers all over New England,
you know,
like seven nights a week.
Comedy was so we got so fucking lucky.
We were born into a time where there was just gigs everywhere in.
So like in the first year that we were doing stand up comedy,
we were on the road seven nights a week,
make you know,
making 25 bucks a pop,
maybe 50 on a good night.
But you were in your glory probably,
right?
You guys were making a living.
It's a shitty living,
but we were just smoking pot during the day.
Let's see,
in movies,
fucking around right material and then go on off to you drive.
We drive.
There was a Gig and it was in Maine and you didn't get a hotel.
It was,
you know,
two and a half hours away.
There was no hotel.
And yeah,
again,
make them like 50 bucks.
You spent half of it on gas and I drive up there with uh,
with another comic and we get there,
we do the show and it's a road house and it's a hell Gig.
And uh,
and I remember bombing so bad that I was on stage and I was doing jokes and they
were,
they were nice.
They weren't heckling,
but they're also not laughing.
And I did a joke and I overheard an older couple in the front row.
The woman said to the man,
the poor bastard,
oh.
Which was worse than being heckled.
And it was pity.
And so there was a couple of waitresses there and me and the other comic hooked
up with the two waitresses and he went to her place.
She drives me to her place.
She's in a trailer and she's got a three year old asleep.
Her mom is there and just says hi to me.
Like I was the boyfriend coming home from college and then takes off.
I go in there and she's a skank and so I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm sure I'm drunk,
but I started sobering up and as we're fooling around I've just realized she's
just too good at this and I don't want to be,
I don't want to be with John Mcenroe of one night stands and man.
And so really you actually have that?
Uh,
like in youth to go like,
um,
I don't,
I'd rather not be that then have sex tonight.
I don't want to be a number of times.
Wow.
But this is also like 25 years ago we're talking to yeah.
You still have that mentality.
Yeah.
Wow.
And so we get naked and I remember her chasing me around the bed trying to put
it in her,
she was grabbing it and trying to pull it into her and me pulling away.
It was like a wrestling match and it ended with,
it ended with oral.
There was a concession of oral,
you're like even today,
then woke up in the morning in her bed and again,
no fucking idea where I am.
I'm in Maine is no Uber,
that's the worst mom.
And so her three year old gets up and comes in and the three year old doesn't
even act shocked.
This is all normal.
And so I,
so I go back to Boston and about about three weeks later I ran into a buddy of
mine and I'm going to tell you off the air who it is,
maybe another Boston comedian.
Yeah.
And I see him in,
this guy was a horn dog and I see him when he goes,
dude,
I just did main last night.
Fuck this girl in her trailer.
I go three year old.
He's like,
yeah.
Ah.
So we call the agent and we go,
we want to do the gig together.
So like three months later we walk into the roadhouse shoulder to shoulder and
we see her,
she's got a tray of drinks,
practically drops the trade drank,
got to after the shell in my buddy's car double team and our what?
Oh,
I forgot to mention a detail.
She's pregnant.
Oh
yeah.
How so?
Much better than my story.
Like pregnant five months while we were there for three months before you do the
math.
Oh,
right.
Who knows?
He didn't know.
He never found out and he never found out.
He never got the call all of these years.
Oh,
cause you gave her mouth babies.
You didn't do.
That's right.
Do you think she did she seem pretty good at that,
like she was,
it was like if,
is there an Olympics for oral sex?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Gold medalist.
Wow.
Yeah.
Really?
That's a good thing about skanks.
You know,
they provide a lot lizards.
Have you ever seen or hadn't experienced in a lot lizard?
God?
No,
but it sounds like she was kind of close.
Like she's a comedy lizard.
Yeah.
What do you call common glazers chocolate fuckers.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well known ones out there.
Like throat Zillows of comedy.
Yeah,
there's a,
yeah,
there's one,
there's one.
I don't want to say anything in specific while we're recording.
Sure.
There's a a,
there's a city that I know of that like a lot of comics have had the experience
with one person.
That's how you,
I'll say you [inaudible] know in Connecticut.
No thought.
No,
but I'll,
I'll tell you,
I'll tell you when we're not recording.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
I got to ask.
Yeah,
that's pretty,
uh,
that's wild dude.
Yeah.
Double teaming her team and her a little bump triple team.
And Are you still in that?
There's another year.
Ah.
Does your wife know what a slut you were?
You know,
we never got anywhere.
Oh,
she hears rumblings,
but she's not interested because we met at 30,
you know,
and you both,
you both have just,
you've been around,
you've both been around.
Like I remember trying to come up,
I used to have a bit about this,
like we are trying to come up with pet names for each other that we hadn't
already used on somebody else.
Oh,
right.
By the end of the week,
I'm Norman and she's dude.
All right.
Cause it's gotta be original to be a new one you haven't used before.
Connie's gone.
Babes gone.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That's why we call it other jeans.
Yeah,
that's true.
You call each other genes.
Genes.
That's our nickname for each other.
Sweet.
Yeah.
It's pretty,
pretty cool.
But Tom was,
we hooked up when Tom was like 25 yeah.
And you still managed to be a real slut.
No,
I wasn't though.
That's the thing is the,
the,
they stand out more to her.
These,
the,
the stories because they weren't my girlfriends.
Yeah.
My number's low.
It's not very high.
Right.
So how's your numbers?
Hello?
I'm not billing.
She was all monogamous.
Like a fucking nerd.
I'm more of relationship lady and AIDS came out when I was in college.
Like then come out with the hysteria.
You have to wear a cotton.
I mean,
I had eight,
so I was in college at the height of like,
you're going to get aids and die,
you know?
Right.
So that was a huge deterrent for me was disease.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Well not like ethical or moral.
I kind of wish I could go back now.
And of course you can imagine if you put your mentality now,
oh my God.
Brain into like 20 year old you.
Yes.
So great.
I know.
What would you do differently?
Just smashed it.
I smashed everything.
I mean that girl was a rare exception.
Really?
Yeah.
I put up big numbers really well.
I was at Boston University and it was just a 30,000 kids.
So like you could have a one night stand.
I never see that person again.
And you're cool with them.
That's crazy.
I just got an email at my website from a woman who said,
uh,
you don't remember me telling me in your ass.
She said she,
she goes,
I remember.
She goes,
you're coming to Boston.
I might come out and see you.
You won't remember me because we hooked up in college and I saw you a week later
and he didn't remember me.
I felt so bad.
Wow.
Yeah.
So,
but you are real slot back then.
Was it booze fueled or was it,
that was a lot of booze.
Oh.
So I think I was just very,
I was highly motivated.
Some people I think are just built to to fight.
I just liked on a night,
what's more fun on a night to start with your buddies,
get a good base of alcohol and the apartment.
Go hit a bar,
go in pursuit
close
and go walk home.
Whether it's the next,
next morning,
walking home at 6:00 AM
your bill,
you have to be built for it though.
I really believe that because I,
here's the thing,
all my sex,
almost all of it almost came to me.
I was never like,
like I would be hanging out with friends who were that guy and then she said no
and she said no and she said,
and I would just be like,
you know,
oh,
someone just came up,
started talking to me.
Yeah.
If this goes somewhere cool.
Right.
That's why I think my numbers were never crazy.
You it's done is a lazy hunter.
I was patty Stacy,
hunter matchmaker.
It would be like you're a lazy,
Lazy.
It's totally true because I,
the big thing for me was like,
I'm not going to put in a lot of effort to this shit.
Yeah.
You know,
plus it comes to me.
Well it wasn't even like that.
It wasn't like from like I'm too good for it.
It was literally being lazy.
What are you good looking in college?
Was He,
he's handsome.
I you're,
you're handsome now.
But I didn't know if you were like,
well here's the thing,
big difference between freshman year and senior year.
Yeah.
About a 70 pounds when I graduated.
Did you play sports?
No.
Yeah.
So,
but I got,
I got to college,
I was fat and by the time I graduated I was in pretty good shape.
So I sit of what most kids do.
I was the opposite.
Yeah.
I lost a bunch of weight.
But the motivation was probably to lose the weight was probably to get more sex.
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
Cause you're like,
you're,
you're in this environment and then you're like,
oh,
you know,
I want to participate more.
So I just lost weight.
Worked out more.
Yeah.
And plus he's just so,
it's just knocking
so many mouths.
Yeah.
My God.
So nasty.
So true.
Anyways,
so you have a 15 year old daughter now.
And how old is your other booboo?
My son is a senior.
Oh one no one's looking at colleges now.
Crazy.
We're at the opposite ends of the spectrum right now.
I know.
I'm,
we're like in today,
he pulled his leg up to his mouth.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's,
it is such a different,
you know,
the crazy thing is,
is you don't spend less mental energy.
Like you guys are putting in the physical and mental energy,
but they get to be teenagers.
It's still just like,
you're constantly,
there's just meetings.
There's strategy meetings every day because you really feel like,
and you know,
most of the,
most of the reading I've done on parenting at this stage is there is not just
control the border because their kid,
their peers are,
have way more of an influence on them right now than you do as a parent.
You,
you guys would,
you are doing now in the first six to eight years is everything in terms of
their morals,
their choices,
um,
you know,
how they pushed themselves,
how they,
how they self,
all those things.
They're learning now because once they're teenagers,
they're just,
they're liars.
Yeah.
Really?
Teenagers just lie and you take it personally.
When it first happens,
like,
like we went out one night and we're like,
we're going to a fucking movie,
hour and a half.
And we come back and like,
we can smell liquor and there's a guy running out the back door when we get
there.
And I just remember I go,
oh yeah,
that's exactly what I did.
Sure.
Yeah.
And then they lie right in your face.
Who is the king runners?
No kid ran out of the back.
Well,
what's the smell of booze?
Sandy rock.
I don't know.
Booze.
I'm just lying constantly.
Yeah.
And so you just got to kind of go like,
all right,
keep them from driving drunk and keep them from getting pregnant,
you know,
to you,
um,
when you,
do you go,
like,
I know that that's alcohol.
Like do you,
do you address the fact that you know,
you're being lied to or do you go like,
I'll just accept that.
I know that,
I know it's a lie.
Well,
the,
the dynamic that we're shooting for is to,
and it's worked with my son.
My son has,
is a different personality than my daughter.
My daughter is very like rebellious,
pushing the limits.
She,
she gets excited by being on the edge.
I like,
I remember when she was maybe six and she's in the living room and she puts her
arms out and she starts spinning really fast for a long time.
Then she falls on her back and while she's laying there,
she goes,
this feels so good.
I was like,
uh,
and so,
so I just try to not create this kind of adversarial environment where she's
going to want to rebel against us and hate us.
And they do the opposite of what we say and we,
and that we've been lucky with that.
We've,
when something happens,
we talked through it,
we try to understand why it's happening.
We try to let her understand where we're coming from.
And so we,
she's very honest when things go wrong and she gets in trouble,
we problem solve it as a team.
That's,
that's very unique.
It's the opposite of the way I was raised,
of course,
which I think is a lot of what our parenting comes from is like,
all right,
what did my parents do wrong?
I'm going to overcompensate for that.
All all things,
but also,
do you think it's,
I mean from what I have learned in years of therapy,
the toddler years come around again in the teen years in a sense,
right?
So how they were as toddlers theoretically is what they're going to be like as
teenagers and also for the,
for them to be rebelling and to be pushing back on you is totally good and
healthy and normal.
And if they weren't,
then I'd be worried.
Right.
The ones that are like [inaudible],
man,
I'm just Christian and we're just going to Bible study.
Like right.
You're going to explode at some point.
Yeah,
and I think the shadow parenting,
it's very hard because as your kids get older,
like you have to shadow parent when your kids are little and they're learning
how to walk,
you have to be a foot away making sure that they don't fall down the stairs.
And then you have to like make this transition every year.
They get older,
you have to take a step back and redefine your relationship with them and give
them more freedom and let them feel autonomous and let them start to,
you know,
uh,
Kay,
like even homework,
they say,
don't ever ask your kid did you do your homework?
See how their grades are.
And if the grades are bad,
then there's repercussions.
Let them figure out and strategize,
get support them,
you know,
read their essays that they write.
Say if you want to show them to me,
I'll give you some feedback.
And asked them if they need support,
but don't hound them every night about,
did you do this?
Did you do that?
You know,
because then it's all external and you're never gonna learn how to do it
themselves and discipline.
Right?
So,
so you have to make this transition from shadow parenting to letting them,
you know,
make their own mistakes and have their own repercussions,
whether it's from friends or from teachers.
And,
and then you just sort of like support,
support,
support.
Yeah.
It's brutal isn't it?
It's really hard.
And then it's true,
their personalities reemerge.
Like my,
my son,
like he's very,
he's very much like,
um,
he doesn't want us to tell him how to do things.
And he was about four and we were at the airport,
we're flying to New York and it was one of these like 6:00 AM flights where you
wake up at three 30 to get to the airport,
haven't had breakfast,
and we've got like an hour before the plane leaves.
So I go to Starbucks to get some breakfast and I come back and I bought him a
blueberry muffin and then I go to give it to him.
And Aaron goes,
no,
that's a chocolate chip muffin.
If he eats chocolate before the flight,
he's going to be bouncing off the walls.
Yeah.
And so I say,
and he's already got it in his hand and I say,
Oh,
and here you can have the muffin top,
but you can't have the whole muffin.
And his face turns red steams kind steam comes out of his ears to how old is he?
He's about four.
And he screams,
yeah.
And everybody in earshot doubles over laughing this kid.
And so,
uh,
and so he's like that as a teenager too.
He,
yeah.
The only time he gets mad is when we try to micromanage.
You know how he should live,
right.
The muffin.
He's a captain of two soccer teams.
Crazy straight A's,
you know,
girlfriend,
nicest politest kid.
Great.
Why fuck with that?
Yeah,
no,
you've done it.
It sounds great.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Home run,
man.
Put all our work on the daughter now.
So fit.
But 15 is a rough age.
What were you like at 15 running the streets?
Really nightmare.
I had already done LSD at Lollapalooza.
Wow.
Smoking cigarettes into a golf clubs.
Golf clubs on school nights and shit.
Like running circles around my parents who weren't paying attention.
That's the thing is that my parents weren't great and they were not paying
attention.
If your folks pay attention,
she can't get it.
How much chicken she get into.
Did you have older siblings?
No,
I was an only child but then I had three stepsisters,
so the middle one and I got into trouble together.
But 15 is rough.
Especially now with social media,
we,
I didn't have that pressure of like,
I hear that teenage girls especially suffer because they're on Instagram.
And then if he didn't get invited to the party,
you get to see,
I didn't get all my daughter,
my daughter was in a funk for three days last week because she didn't get
invited to a party.
Let's Tara and I do.
And you just look at them and you go,
I wish there was something I could do or say.
And you just realize now they just have to suffer.
And it's,
it's so much.
You're right,
it's more frequent now and it's deeper now because not only did you not get
invite,
you can see who did get it right and everybody's looks better than you.
Yeah.
The best pictures.
And you could see who's skinnier and hotter and who's got the cute her
boyfriend.
It's like,
it's way more pressure now back at least in the 90s,
we had these anti heroes as girls.
Like you had,
um,
you know,
Janeane Garofalo you had,
um,
the grunge look or whatever you had like Kathleen Hanna and Bikini kill.
Like you actually had anti girls.
They were Rad.
Yeah.
That thought,
that kind of stuff.
I grew up onto the eightball comics and now I don't know what the anti girl
culture is cause it's all Maine.
It's all Ariana Grande.
I like girls who look perfect and are a perfect,
I don't know what girls are looking through.
You don't see the the goth girls anymore.
There's no sub culture and there's no anti girly culture right now that I know
of that a young woman can be like,
yeah,
I might,
I'm not perfect.
I'm not a Barbie.
I'd rather be a little stinky,
a little weird,
a little punk,
a little whatever you have the Kardashians needed like a fat younger days.
They did and then they gave her plastic surgery and they stopped all our fat out
and now she's hot.
Yeah.
Which one was that?
He used to be,
wasn't Chloe the chunky and Kylie was normal of profile the dude as much and
then they did and he was fat or it was like you're fat and gross.
So they ain't tried to lose some weight.
And the WHO is the dude's brother?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So he got like,
you know,
he got a lot of attention because he's part of the group,
but they still would manage to shame him,
make him be like that.
Doesn't it suck that hot,
your family here,
but could you imagine it now like social media as a teenager has got to be
horrendous?
No,
that would,
I think I would,
I think I struggled a lot with teen.
Just the pressures of fitting into groups.
I was always switching schools.
I think.
I think the reality of that without social media was a lot for me to handle.
I think that would be much worse with it.
I think it'd be much harder.
There's a lot of stuff that our kids are going to go through that we did and I
mean,
first of all,
school shootings.
Oh my God.
You know,
that's something that hangs over.
I mean,
they see it in the news all the time.
Regularly.
They,
uh,
my,
my daughter,
when she was in second grade,
there's a park across the street from her school and they were at this park.
It was like,
you know,
spring sucking,
play day where they have little contests and races and,
and there was a shooter who drove past and shots were fired over the park.
Oh.
Can they all had to dive on each other.
My daughter dove on a,
on a little preschooler and laid on top of her and then they had to go into this
like,
um,
rec area and stay in the basement for like three hours because the guy was on
the loose for like an hour.
He killed like four people.
Remember what Santa Monica killed like four people and then they killed him at
Santa Monica College.
Oh good.
So she experienced the school shooting in second grade.
We didn't have to deal with that.
No,
no,
no.
That's crazy.
And,
and I think they are picking up on,
you know,
your kids will hopefully,
hopefully the world will change,
but politically I just know,
you know,
they're,
they're looking at a world with,
you know,
politics that's so divisive and so toxic and they're looking at,
they know that the,
the does global warming.
They understand that,
you know,
they're looking at these dates to come out in the news.
I can 2030 if we don't turn things around,
it's too late and the,
and they're,
they're,
look,
they're going to be old during that time.
I'm,
I'm sorta like,
fuck it.
I'll be dead.
Yeah.
But they're going to be dealing with that.
Well,
I will say to the millennials credit and to this,
I don't know what's,
what's the generation after millennials,
I don't know.
Gen Y,
Gen y,
whatever,
is that they do have more of a consciousness about this stuff and the global
consciousness that we just don't have.
Right.
Because of the Internet and they create businesses that help the world and shit
like that.
So I don't know.
I think they're good.
I think they're going to create stuff that's going to help.
Yeah,
they have totally different consciousness.
I know they are.
They're good people and they are.
Yeah,
they don't,
they,
they like,
they have incorporated capitalism with like causes and shit.
Yeah.
Whereas our generation was like,
fuck capitalism man.
Reagan's,
you know.
Yeah.
Anti materialistic.
Right,
right.
They better be at 10 materialistic and not making any fucking money.
They're all going to be broke.
Everything's going to be automated by the time they get out of college.
Yeah,
that's true.
Did anyways,
here's a Fart Mike,
in case you have any,
I forgot to tell you earlier,
what's the Fart?
It's just if you have to Fart,
we prefer the really,
all right.
Mine are a little corny today.
Really dry driving up here.
I had an essence of ethanol to it.
Yeah.
What do you think that's from?
Um,
well last night our refrigerator died.
So last night we just ate everything that was in the freezer,
like frozen pizzas role and of course the fridge,
you know it,
the guy came today,
it needs like some kind of,
there's a starter in a refrigerator that died,
so we just killed it.
We just threw everything in the microwave and just sat in front of the TV.
You Watch Sopranos and fucking ate shitty.
That's awesome.
Now you must have some crazy for it.
Yeah.
The farts are in tents.
That's a great day to be here.
I just hope I can,
you know,
show up.
Well,
let me know when it's ready.
Okay.
I'll turn it on.
All right,
good.
So we got to get it out from under a no,
this is dangerous right now and the way it's rigged.
Yeah.
Little dangerous to be watched the show dirty John.
No.
Okay.
You gotta get into it.
What is it?
Netflix.
A con man show.
No,
no,
it's on Bravo TV and he seduces women.
Then he steals half their money and shit and he's real psycho.
Nice.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Get your daughter into watch it so she can be aware that their psychosis.
She dating,
she dating,
not dating.
Okay,
good.
She's a,
she's a surfer.
She spends a lot of times,
so no,
she goes,
you should go before school.
You should,
you should pull it to the left under here.
Like that.
Sorry guys.
We're having difficulties like ready to go for ethanol farts a couple of days a
week.
She gets up before school and goes and surfs in February in what?
In the Pacific Ocean,
which is really good kid.
Yeah,
she's intense
man.
Wow.
Yeah.
That sounds wild though.
And then,
uh,
they,
and then she's,
she serves for her high school team.
Yeah,
that's her,
that's her gym class.
It counts as a gym press.
I wish I could have done that.
Maybe these competitions all up and down the coast.
These surf against kids from San Francisco and San Diego and realize like when
she goes to college or even for the rest of her life and tells that to 99.9%
you're making that up.
Right,
right,
right.
You surfed for school.
I doesn't sound real.
I want to join her shit now.
Yeah,
it's a she.
She's got a good,
and then skate.
There's a skateboard park in Venice beach.
You ever been to that?
I've seen it.
It's really intense.
They spent some money and they,
but it's like,
uh,
all the,
all the kind of tough punk skater kids hang out there and that's where she
spends a lot of her time.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's good though.
I'll tell you why.
She's going to be a badass bitch.
She will be a bad ass shit.
I ain't take shit from nobody.
She's already talking about the tattoos and you know,
we're not a teen.
I don't need your permission,
but if you give me your permission now,
I'll help you pick the one that,
yeah,
no,
I don't fall for that.
Yeah,
you guys have tattoos?
I have one tramp stamp I got in the 90s yeah.
What is it?
It's a dragon.
It's the lamest.
I hate it and I want it.
I want it removed.
You hit that Shit Tom,
all the time.
I got the word poison under my waistband with an Arrow pointing to my dick
chicks.
Dig that.
A lot of college girls were into this,
stop
Craig's,
you happen.
He really likes that.
He really took hold the Greg fancy without,
I think the is all going to get Irish harps wants the kids are old enough.
Really?
That's cool.
Yeah.
Cause you know that was a symbol of the rebellion against the British when they
occupied us as they,
they tried to kill our culture by not allowing us to speak to speak Gaelic or
play the harp.
And so they would hide harps in the basements of farms in the country and then
they would sneak out there and they would,
uh,
they would have sessions,
music sessions,
and they play the harp
harp.
So you play the harp now almost constantly.
If you have you done shows?
No,
dude,
I'm looking to,
yeah,
bring me with you,
man.
I'll go with Ya.
What'd you really fuck?
Yeah,
I'll go,
go.
I'll go for no money.
Just bring me,
oh my goodness.
Because my family wants to go too.
And I think we're,
I think we're planning a trip,
not this summer,
but the following summer with my mom and sister and everything.
So,
um,
yeah,
I mean it shows her apparently amazing.
I heard,
I think I would feel kind of dumb though.
They're just so,
they're,
their language is so much broader than ours and so much more colorful.
Do you know that I did a show once abroad where I was given credit for a concept
in the joke that I wasn't doing,
like in the writer,
like a,
they were like,
and then I read the explanation of how smart it was and I was like,
that's not what I was doing.
And you're like,
that was a Fart joke.
No,
I was just like,
I was,
they were like,
and then he doubled back on it showing us how his critique of like he was
playing the part of a dumb person as he said,
I was just speaking how I speak his persona and his sad tire we're dead on.
Nope.
That was just being me.
Yeah,
you're right.
They are.
Yeah,
definitely.
Yeah.
There's,
there's like just a richer vocabulary.
Yeah.
They are way smarter than us and Europeans.
I'd say in general they say their high school education as equals like our
college education.
Absolutely.
I studied one year abroad in England and for college that,
that one year I learned more than my entire education in the u s were you
struggling where you like behind the other students?
Um,
I don't know.
It's different system there.
It's the tutorial system,
so I don't know the other kids,
it's like a one on one shit,
so.
Right.
You didn't,
I don't know what other people got,
you know,
they're all smart.
Yeah.
Think so.
I remember my
classes,
what I did,
I did a semester in Madrid and all those classes at University of Madrid were
way more intense than the ones back home.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
Yeah.
He's fluent in Spanish.
I mean,
I pretty good.
I was completely rocking and rolling in that era because back then too,
not really.
I actually didn't get Spanish.
I didn't,
I'd love to hear how loud was right.
Damn.
And now I know.
I really didn't,
but,
but man,
the class,
I mean you were those,
they didn't set us up like Americans for classes in Spain.
They just registered us for classes at the university.
Right.
So you're with this general pop.
Oh yeah.
So it wasn't English speaking classes.
Oh Wow.
We're doing term papers and everything in Spanish,
you know,
with,
with Spanish students.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That was intense.
Yeah.
My kids both,
uh,
they go to a Spanish immersion program.
So he started in kindergarten and hat and they spoke two thirds of their classes
for the first three years were only in Spanish and half the kids are spent from
Spanish speaking homes.
So they homes and so they,
so they like have no,
they're,
they're fluid.
They still take three classes a day in Spanish,
in high school.
And like,
we went to Spain and they're like,
oh yeah,
they don't have an American accent.
They have like a Central American accent because all their teachers are native
speakers.
So that's just how they learned it.
Do you speak anything else besides English?
French real?
Say something fancy.
A lick.
My scrum.
Uh,
like my be home,
you know,
you can just say something else.
Huma,
Paul,
I'll say,
you know what,
I speak it well in Montreal,
way better than in France.
Montreal.
They are like,
Hey,
this'll be fun.
Let's talk friends together.
You know,
he talked to the cab driver,
they're totally into it.
You go to France and you speak in French and they answer you in English.
They know
Tommy here with Spanish where,
um,
I used to do a bit about it that,
that when I would speak Spanish to,
uh,
a guy who clearly speaks Spanish,
like as in my mind as a way to just ease up,
you know,
make,
make it easier.
Yeah.
Like I know you speak Spanish,
I speak Spanish.
I'll just speak Spanish to you.
They would answer me in English.
Yeah.
And it was like,
they didn't like my assumption that I needed to speak Spanish.
Right,
right.
They would always ask me back in English and I'm like,
why are you doing my Spanish was better than your,
like why were just like,
well,
my English was good enough.
Well,
a lot of times for first generation,
um,
Spanish speakers in this country,
they,
they don't want to be associated with recent immigrants and so they won't speak
it.
And that's part of the proud,
this Spanish immersion program in Santa Monica.
It's called Edison Language Academy.
It's a public school and they can't get Spanish
speakers because the,
they don't realize that their kids have an asset to be bilingual in this world,
but they are like,
no,
I don't want my kids speak in Spanish.
And it's like,
Nah,
it's like an insecurity that's keeping them from gap.
Right.
Um,
are you familiar with Dad boners now?
So there's a certain type of guy.
It's usually guys,
honestly,
they're usually white guys and they get a level of excitement that is off the
charts.
Like the type of excitement you should reserve for like winning the lottery or
something,
but they get it for just goofy Shit Shit that you shouldn't get excited for it
all.
And we'd love featuring them and showing them.
So there's a new one,
but to get to the new one,
we want to show you like the exemplary dad boner.
Okay.
So this guy made a video of him coming to a part in the Trans Canada highway
where like it,
where,
where was it connected at some point and look at it,
how thrilled he is at a fucking highway.
Okay.
This is just to give you an idea.
So here's where it was paved.
I finally found this section where it was paved.
All right.
[inaudible] is the Trans Canada highway baby [inaudible] a bird.
It's Columbia.
The kilometer marker 7128th.
And this is where I believe with a 90%,
uh,
no mix,
that 95% chance that this is in fact the very place where the Trans Canada
paved.
It's last.
Let's go for a run on her.
How's on asphalt belt and there says debacle.
Woo.
I want to see if I can,
I gotta be careful here,
but
I don't want
slide.
Okay.
It's a real person.
I'm so jealous that he could summon that excitement.
Right?
I mean,
here's the thing.
And then he joyful.
Sometimes we've been sent clips of like a guy with a similar reaction to let's
say,
um,
well,
uh,
train.
We'll see what that would be appropriate.
I'm saying the ones that don't fit would be somebody seeing something in nature
like whale watching and they'll react.
I'm like,
yeah,
but that's,
that merits a huge reaction seeing something amazing.
Seeing a fucking highway.
It's like,
dude,
get your shit together.
Inanimate object and what's going on?
Their train thing of course was nuts.
So here's a new one.
Are you ready?
You haven't seen
God.
I love these.
We're here for you.
Look over there.
It's a vintage old Otis elevator.
Elevators and Florida in elevators.
Both film these before.
Oh,
look at the sign and leveled,
right?
Oh,
let's wait for it to close.
Nice elevator.
Okay,
awesome.
I love the smell of eight.
Are these your fixtures?
Otis with black buttons like the one at the Houston club building.
But unfortunately it got demolished.
You start jacking off in the motor.
Here we go.
Hit a number on the back of his hand.
It's a holocaust survivor hydro.
Ah,
it's an elevator down.
Anything worse than getting in a shitty elevator.
Like when you get into like,
and you can hear the oh well,
and apparently he hasn't lived in a shitty apartment complex.
That's pretty exciting.
Yeah,
man.
If I know,
if you go to a fountain and vine,
there's a couple of ones might be thrilled.
Some Otis ones in Hollywood.
Jack Your Dick in any of the places we used to live in.
What's the,
what's the last thing you kind of got that excited about?
Oh God.
Lexapro.
I'm trying to think.
You saw,
you'd make fun of,
you said,
I get excited about,
I dunno.
Crime shows.
Getting seen.
Serial killers,
Ted Bundy,
new get new movies,
Hitler docs,
stuff like that.
Not to get that level of excited like that.
How about you?
Oh,
I know
my,
uh,
my friend and bought a,
an old five 60 sl,
those Mercedes like the convertibles.
That's cool.
And she,
she fully restored it and I just,
I don't know.
I used to be a parking attendant for years.
Yeah.
And I,
and that car,
this Guy Ron Machete who was a,
he was the lawyer for the Gambino crime family and he used to pull up in that
car and I used to fucking joy if you're listening,
Ron,
for Shetty.
Thank you.
And uh,
sorry about the gas and I used,
I would,
you're right,
it,
we say it was fucking,
the thing was a tank and wait like 3000 pounds,
but it was a v eight and that thing flew,
but it just had the smoothest ride.
And so when she pulled up in that I had to,
I had to drive and she let me drive it and it's got the giant steering wheel.
I know you're talking about with the power steering.
So you got parents excited about that.
Yeah,
I get excited.
Happy.
I really like cars.
Yeah.
So that,
but I mean I don't even,
yeah,
I probably would on,
on,
on a certain day if you show me a certain car,
I might geek out.
Yeah.
But what cars?
Muscle cars.
No,
I mean I like,
I dunno,
I,
I geeked out as a kid over a lot of exotics.
You know,
and then that's just like sports.
I didn't really,
I wasn't really in the land bows,
but like I like sports cars in general,
so like Porsche's,
um,
be certain BMWs.
I even like Mercedes,
like AMG gts I think are awesome.
But yeah,
I mean I've seen Ferrari's,
certain ones in person where I've definitely been like,
Holy Shit,
look at this thing.
Yeah.
Cause it looks like a,
like a painting.
It was like a piece of artwork.
It is.
And it's,
and it's great because you can drive it.
Yeah.
It's like a piece of art that you can actually take out an experience again and
again.
And you know,
they say money can't buy happiness,
but some true,
if you have a car that brings you joy every time you get in it,
that that improves your life.
That does.
Yeah.
It does.
If you get in a car where when you start the engine you're like,
ah,
that's,
that's happening to you every day.
Yeah.
No,
I always liked old,
a old mustangs.
And that,
that rumble when you'd sit down and you just felt it underneath here.
Part of
it.
Yeah.
And the noise of it and yeah.
I think those 66 Mustang.
Yeah,
those are,
those are pretty choice,
man.
What's the fastest car you've ever owned?
The fastest car I've ever owned.
Um,
nothing crazy now.
No,
I've never had like a lightening fast car.
I mean everybody now too,
like even Rogan was saying,
you know,
that his uh,
he got that a Tesla and that it's way faster than is a gt three Rs.
No Shit.
Yeah.
He's like,
this thing is insane.
Wow.
And they're releasing a new one test is going to release a roadster that goes
zero to 60 in 1.9 seconds.
She was like,
yeah,
that's out of this world.
I mean,
there's nothing like that.
That's like a second faster than a Ferrari.
I mean,
one to 60 miles an hour.
come on,
let's do doing a quarter mile in like eight seconds.
Damn,
that's,
that's a really real question is how fast can it stop?
I know who he is.
Important.
Very important.
Yeah.
And they're doing it.
By the way,
that roads,
there will be $200,000,
which is a lot of money,
but it's a fraction of the cost of the cars that are performing at that speed.
Yeah.
So you know,
you're talking about La Ferrari or a McLaren.
Um,
see,
I know,
or the six,
seven,
whatever it is,
six 70 LP,
those cars that are in that two and a half to three second rate,
third hundreds of thousands more.
Yeah.
Some of them were
over a million dollars.
Right.
And then test is like 200 grand.
Go 1.9 seconds.
Tesla needs something right to come back.
Aren't they in trouble financially?
They've been in financial kind of trouble,
but I dunno,
I mean if this a model three really works out,
that's where that's the chief saved,
right?
Yeah.
That's,
that could be the savior.
How much is that going to cost?
It's supposed to be 35 grand.
Take one.
Oh,
that's,
I have a,
I have a Prius right now and uh,
I'm kinda done.
I'm kind of done your day.
What's going on?
I've had it for eight years and I just never felt,
I just,
I feel a little in it.
And I think maybe because I'm a small person that's like a complex for me sure.
Is when like,
uh,
like this guy in a pickup truck just pulled up next week,
I cut him off apparently I didn't mean to,
but it was a merging situation and he wasn't giving me room and I,
I took it,
he followed me home and I was taking extra turns to see if he was following me.
And he was in one of those big,
like,
you know,
Ford F two fifties,
which is so fun and cool cleaning equipment in the back or something.
Yeah.
You're a Douche if you live in a city and you drive a pickup just to drive a
pickup.
Yeah.
You're a,
yeah.
And so he follows me to my house and I stopped like a block short and he pulls
up next to me and he goes,
hey,
you cut me off when you're faggoty car.
And I just started laughing.
I was like,
Ooh.
Faggoty
that's really made me led.
So,
and it totally disarmed him.
He didn't know how to handle it.
Yeah.
Cause he wanted me to push back.
Sure.
And I saw him pick something up as he pulled up next to me.
Fuck.
So I was scared.
But then the laughter just diffuse the whole situation and then I let them
curse.
He did an ice chest full of curses for me and then he pulled off and that was
it.
Wow.
You imagine.
I mean
crazy.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
I mean I've gotten mad like anybody else,
but I'm not follow you.
Yeah.
I had one time a guy accidentally,
I cut off the freeway traffic and he started to swerve his car to pretend he was
going to try to threaten to hit my car.
You know what I'm saying?
Like he was like,
man,
like that's a psychomotor.
And I was like,
Whoa Bro.
I was maybe 26 years old.
I was like in a Chevy Nova.
Like when are you doing bro?
Like I was with you one time where you scared the shit out of me when you were
at the wheel.
We were at,
we were the second car to stop sign going to turn on to a busier street and the
car in front of us like just didn't go right away.
She's like,
ha ha ha.
I was like,
oh boy.
And then when we finally turn it was a car,
three guys and they just start to chill back to see like what's up with Rondi
Hawkins?
And I'm like,
yeah,
I'm sure the only reason I bad bad go with us more as the assault of the other
guys in the car.
Yeah.
But then I was like,
you are,
I never,
this side,
I must have been a weird day for me jeans.
I was like,
do you always drive like this?
Like come on,
go.
No.
I must've been going through something that really want to be seen with you that
recently,
Evan,
I'd scare the shit out of me.
Like,
is this what you always do?
I said before therapy maybe.
Maybe.
Maybe it was a while ago.
Yeah.
It sounds like it's scarred you.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
no,
I think about it all the time.
I was like,
Shit,
because it puts you totally campaign.
They're not going to hit her.
They're going to hit,
you know,
and then also I'm like,
great,
I got to get ready to fight right now.
Yeah,
you couldn't wait two seconds at the stop sign.
That's the plan man.
Just try and get you to fucking fight you guy or what?
Yeah,
because been a purse.
I had this guy one time and I was driving my son to preschool and so he's like,
what is that for preschool?
So he's sitting in the back and I get to a four way stop and this guy runs his
stop sign and goes wide in front of my car.
And so I honk at him and then he gives me the finger but he can't get past me
cause he went so wide.
So I got out of my car and I went up and I punched his window as hard as I could
and then he pulled away and I stood in the middle of the road,
waving them back and I look over and I see my son just staring at him and like
good modeling.
And so the guy kept going and then cut to like two weeks later I'm at a kid's
party and there's a little bouncy house and I'm watching my kid and this guy,
Jeff is standing next to me and he's watching his kid,
we're drinking fucking juice boxes and hate in life.
And he goes,
uh,
he goes,
that was me.
Oh,
I go,
what are you talking about?
He goes,
you punched my window a couple of weeks ago.
That was you.
And he was a guy who,
uh,
he,
he created lost.
He,
he,
oh,
he was the,
he wrote the pilot with Jj Abrams.
Oh my God.
So he had a good take me back to what led to that though?
He went wide on the turn so wide that I had to slam on my brakes and then I
jumped out of the car because,
so he was stopped though once you once that?
Yeah.
And then you get out of your car.
I get out of my car,
punch the passenger window.
Were you afraid you break the glass though?
What did you punch a window?
I have rage problems.
Oh,
right,
right.
I've been arrested three times for fighting seriously is why I quit drinking.
Yeah.
That's,
I would never,
and I know I'm a very different person,
so docile and sweet.
Yep.
A lot of therapy.
Lot of therapy.
And I quit drinking.
Yeah.
That's probably huge.
She always have almost always had when I was drinking and uh,
the lights just go and I just,
I just snap.
But at that time you were
sober.
Yeah.
And so when you,
when he tells you that was me,
we laughed.
But it wasn't a good enough of a laugh to release all the awkwardness.
Yeah.
Right.
You know,
because I think we both have rage problems.
Him also.
Yeah.
Did He,
uh,
that's nice then.
Do you think that that he knew,
he knew?
Like when,
when he saw he was like,
that's Greg when you did it or no?
Yeah.
Oh,
you do.
And I think he knew that I was in a white rage and didn't even take in.
Maybe.
Maybe the light was hitting the glass.
I couldn't seem as well or whatever,
but I didn't recognize him.
Did you you,
so you knew him though at the time?
Oh yeah.
I knew him,
but you just didn't realize that we didn't realize it was him.
Fuck yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You could have gone right through that window.
I now,
but I really think my kids,
if my kids have seen me get angry a number of times,
I try to control it.
But you know,
my father had it.
My father used to fucking,
I remember one time he,
uh,
he grabbed,
we were in a bar and he,
I saw him grab a guy and throw him against the wall and he used to come home
with,
he came home with a black eye one time and uh,
yeah,
he was,
he was a real,
he was six foot two from the Bronx.
So I got it from him,
I think.
Uh,
most definitely.
Yeah.
Plus that's a generation that they didn't have therapy or talking.
You're considered a massive pussy if you share your feelings and that stuff.
Right.
So,
yeah,
I think it's in New York thing also for sure.
Cultural.
It's,
it's Irish.
It's very Irish.
I wrote a book called Dear Mrs Fitzsimmons and it was a collection of letters
that were sent to my mother throughout my life from from school,
like bad report cards,
let us was principal and then she would clip out when I would get arrested for
like vandalism as a teenager.
She would cut it out of the paper and she had,
I found a shoe box and the in the Bronx and the basement and it was a,
it was like a fucking trophy case of everything I'd ever done wrong in I life.
Now that's an odd choice that a parent would keep those things.
I wouldn't personally,
that's not something I would keep children's.
Right.
You know,
they would laugh,
they would read it.
Oh they would.
There was one time where I was at a,
I was supposed to be at school,
but there was a golf tournament and we went to a Westchester country club and we
drank all day was my,
me and my friend Nick Zappia,
he had a motorcycle.
This is when he would drink and drive a motorcycle and we went to the golf
tournament.
We drank all day and there's a,
and there's a,
um,
so I go home and the next day we're at dinner and my father goes,
so I was cool yesterday.
I got a fucking sunburn.
I'm like,
it was good.
It was good.
What'd you learn?
I go,
you know,
the usual math and reading catcher in the Rye,
everything's fun.
And he goes,
oh,
that's interesting.
And he pulls out the New York Times and the front page of the Sports Section is
Gary Hall Burger hitting a wood out of the woods.
And me standing behind him,
watching him hit the shot and he showed it to me and then they fucking laugh
their asses off.
They did.
They laughed every time they thought it was,
cause it's Irish,
it's like an Irish thing of like being rebellious.
This is great.
Yeah.
That's kind of fucking awesome.
I mean it's not in like a parenting handbook where it's pretty awesome.
It's pretty great.
I secretly,
when my son is a little rebellious,
I like it.
I am like,
yeah,
you put a brick in it bro.
Like I'd rather him be like that.
Then compliant and docile.
I'd rather him be a little like,
this is what I'm going to fuck you.
You,
you know he's three.
He'll go,
I'd like to play alone.
Please.
I see myself in that sort of like,
once you just get away from me.
He's always saying,
especially when I'm like,
hey buddy,
I give him like a kiss I love.
He's like,
please let me play alone.
All right,
awesome.
I have to go like the other side of the room.
Give me a little fucking space.
It's great.
I love it.
I liked it.
It communicates that way.
Really healthy.
Thank God.
Before we forget,
I don't even know if we addressed it.
Where can people see you coming up?
We were told Jesus for new podcasts,
it's Alison Rosen.
It's called childish and it's on,
you know the usuals iTunes and the childish pod.
Subscribed,
subscribe,
rate,
review,
subscribe,
check it out.
It's doing really well.
We got on all the charts and we got a lot of Nice reviews from people.
Childish Pod,
it's just called childish.
Childish Pod is the media is all childish pod on Twitter.
And then I got some standup date.
And then Fitz dog radio is my podcast.
You guys have been on that,
but at the time,
and then I got some dates coming up.
I will be at the Eagle,
something casino in Michigan
and Howling Eagles.
February 27 February 28th through March 2nd at the grand rapids,
Michigan.
Dr. Grant,
Dr grinned at the Bob Wright and then I'll be at the sycamore tavern.
March 12th Springfield Mass March 15 through six 14 through 16 and then,
uh,
March 17th at the Hollywood improv.
I do my big Saint Patrick's day shell.
Oh God.
You guys are around.
I'd love to have you.
Uh,
on it.
We have our baptism.
We marched on Saint Patrick's Day.
We did intentionally.
No,
you're right.
He did bro.
So we don't have to take another class.
It falls in like,
there's like a schedule.
When took the class here,
our first kid baptized and then we have to schedule obviously the second son and
they're like,
if you do it in this window,
you don't have to take class.
Oh no shit.
We're like,
we'll see you march.
Cause if we waited a month or something we'd have to do the whole thing again.
So how Catholic are you guys?
Not Very.
Just as a family thing.
It's called doing.
We're literally doing,
cause my parents are alive,
right?
Yeah.
We didn't do it in a,
I'm convinced my mother did it behind our backs because unit with Catholics,
it doesn't have to be a priest.
Anybody who's a Catholic who is in good standing,
who's done their confession and taking their communion recently can um,
can grab a kid and uh,
do a few prayers through,
took those fucking classes for right.
Well not only that,
we were going to get married on a beach.
My Dad was like,
buddy,
you will break everybody's heart if you do that.
And I was like,
what?
Yeah,
you got to do it in the church.
And then when I first,
when we were talking about the are older kid getting baptized,
I was like,
yeah,
I don't care what my parents were like,
what?
I was like,
alright,
sure.
Fine.
Yeah.
That's what I feel about almost all of it.
Like,
yeah.
All right.
We'll give them the option if he wants to be Catholic.
He's already in the system.
Yeah.
Big Deal.
Grown further apart from it.
Oh,
like,
no.
Like I was raised like pretty Catholic and I'm like,
I don't care.
Yeah.
I was raised in CCD class on Wednesday,
mass on Sunday and the,
all the,
uh,
all the sacraments.
I loved it.
I don't think good.
And then I had a very,
I was very upset when I realized that a lot of it was a made up.
Yeah.
I love,
they violated by that.
I loved it as a,
as a small kid.
I loved it.
Even like eight,
nine,
10 years old,
I was like,
oh,
this is great.
I had a whole thing I talked to,
I talked to God,
you know,
I,
in my head I talked to him.
It wasn't like the usual,
like begging for shit when you need it from God.
It was just more like,
I really,
they,
you know,
I grew up in a great church.
It was very like a progressive and I liked the priests and you know,
CCD classes were very enlightening,
great parents were teaching and I just felt really comfortable with it.
I didn't have,
there's a lot of shame.
Yeah I think.
But you know,
I think a lot of the new testament stuff really I connected with but it's all
gone now.
Your kids are they my daughter I think because she grew up with so many Latina
kids with the crosses and the first communions and all that.
And then my mother is Super Catholic so she takes them a church all the time.
My daughter loves it and she does.
She wants to know every,
she's a very deep thinker.
My daughter can sit and stare into space for a half an hour straight.
She was always like that.
And so she was captivated by the mythology of the church and like,
you know,
we'll go to church and she want me to explain like the transfiguration and the
ascension and all the,
all the heavy stuff and,
and it makes her,
like,
she,
we went into a church one day and she lit a candle and was sitting there
kneeling.
She was seven years old.
I was like,
what are you doing?
And she goes,
I'm praying for your father.
Never met my dad.
I was like,
wow,
hmm,
whoa.
And your is your son into it?
No,
no,
no.
He's a into dianetics right now.
He thinks he thinks it will help his acting career.
Now he's right at well fucking soap.
So gullible till I was like,
oh no,
I didn't want to say anything negative when he was looking straight A's.
It's like the boy scouts,
but it's dianetics
dude.
And you are the best.
Uh,
absolutely.
When I say this,
I've,
I've not,
I don't say this about most people.
One of the best comedians I've ever seen really is every time,
anywhere.
And you're onstage.
I make it a point.
Yes.
Stay in the room.
And that's really nice.
Thank you so much Amy.
You are one of the best.
Go see him live a download,
subscribe rate and review the childish podcasts that he's down doing with uh,
Alison Rosen who,
uh,
got bless hope everything's well.
Yeah.
In the hospital.
And um,
that's that.
That's it.
Thank you for coming to me on.
Great saying.
Yeah,
we'll be back to loving each other,
all of us after this quick break.
And finally,
I mean finally people are like,
what's the beef?
Do you guys have beef?
It's like,
yeah man,
we've been butting heads for years,
but we were able to squash that beef just for the podcast in the world.
Sure.
Good friend,
hilarious comedian Kyle Kinane.
Oh No,
no.
It's weird.
People say Shit like that and they'll be like,
absolutely no.
Just like when you have like obviously we've been friends with Kyle for over a
decade and then it just occurs to you,
you're like,
oh yeah,
we've never podcasted but I've never,
I never,
I don't know.
I've never given thought to something like that.
Like you just go like,
I dunno what that hurts.
Well,
I'm sorry,
but I mean,
have we been friends this whole time that I thought so.
I mean,
I just don't,
I don't know.
I sometimes
you look at the a list of names that you realize you're like,
oh,
I've never podcasted with this person.
But it's only for just absent minded.
Yeah.
What about the forgettable Kyle Kinane we can have,
no,
you're not forgetting how we got beef,
Bro.
No,
you're amazing.
You're amazing.
And you came here to start beef.
I love it.
I fucking,
I dunno.
I think you're very funny.
Why didn't you have Kyle on before?
Oh,
he's very busy.
He's always on the road.
He's always doing stuff.
I've been around for like six weeks right now guys.
And he's a chapstick enthusiast?
Yeah.
Oh God.
I'm into that lip balm.
What kind of you?
God,
let's talk about it.
You know what?
This is a random one at home at my house that didn't have a label on it.
So,
oh,
let me look at it.
Open it up.
I'll tell you what though.
Gee,
it looks,
Oh gee medicated.
Yeah,
right when it go original,
does it smell like an original chapstick?
Is it kind of Medicaid?
Yeah.
Mediciny I think it's just,
Oh gee,
hmm.
Ooh,
oh by the way,
Kyle,
we have a fart mind here.
I don't know what you had for lunch,
but if you feel like farting,
there's a microphone here and just let me know and we'll turn it on and you can
fire it into it.
Oh,
it's her idea who's taking,
who's taking you up on that?
Oh,
let her answer that.
I mean I have have has a guest farted yet.
Nope.
What's the,
what's the maintenance of that microphone between
usually goes from,
Christine has asked to the desk.
She didn't,
she didn't want us to,
when we met,
we were having this studio set up and I was like,
so we'll shoot next week.
And she was like,
is the Fart Mike Ready?
I was like,
I'm not really worried about that.
And she was like,
why are we even moving to that studio?
Which 12 year old version of what he was like one day.
Cause I had mixed.
I'd mix tapes.
I've just farting at a boombox fact that you have the actual,
what does that sm 58 I'm sure the Shure sm 58 sorry,
this is the 48 did you go into guitar center with like the specifics of like,
I need a microphone for a very,
very special specialized.
There's a specific mission where I'm like,
is it unidirectional?
Oh yeah,
it's coming down from,
it's a one way.
What did you say you fired out of a boom.
Box it into a boombox back when you could just record that it has the built in
microphone.
That was the funniest thing I could've ever heard as a child was to fart and
then play it back.
Yeah,
just blasted into the Magnavox.
Yeah.
How old were you think that's smart.
I think I said too.
I think I'd be single digits.
Oh yeah.
I think I was even younger than that.
Back when the double deck,
the double deckers Dina,
you hear that single digits maybe eight or nine years old.
He was that.
He was,
he invented fart and here's a fart Mike.
Right now for us.
I'll see what I can do here.
You're more than welcome to it,
you know,
just give us a signal if you don't mind.
I haven't had my mom's like,
she was sad with what I've done.
Let's see.
We can get that ticker count.
Are you on a Vegan Diet?
Vegetarian,
which means I made some Mac and cheese and I made a can of Amy's Chili and I
just mixed them together today.
Me being a chef
coffee,
I might just shit right into the thing.
Oh yeah.
Dude.
Can you imagine how fucking epic that would be for a podcast clip?
Kyle grabbed the fart Mike and they shit all over
in the podcasting world.
He left Hollywood.
A lot of people do stuff that's career ending.
He truly executed his own career.
Man.
I wish that would happen right when shit on the FARC.
Mike,
this guy doesn't know how to do anything.
Half assed speed.
I'm going to be a go get her in this town,
man.
That's for sure.
I've met Kyle,
uh,
32 years ago when we started stand up and went back one.
Yeah,
we did our,
uh,
comedy central half hours.
That's right.
Same night.
Oh man,
that you put that picture up a few weeks ago.
Yup.
That was the same night.
I look at all the half hours now and people like the audience was great,
everything was great.
I'm like,
I hated it.
Yeah.
It was miserable.
I remember how nerve racking it was like the going into it,
you know,
like there was like this stepping stone,
uh,
kind of thing.
You would try to figure out like,
oh,
people get hours,
but before that you get half an hour and I don't know about you,
but I was,
I was having my managers submit.
Yeah.
And so it was like the first year they said,
well,
no,
but you're on the radar.
And then I was like,
oh,
okay.
And then the second year,
right.
Good manager thing to say that nobody gives a fuck about you.
Yeah.
You're on the radar and the radar
that's casting every,
every casting session they really loved.
The next year
it was,
um,
they are the hero.
No,
but you're going to get one.
I was like,
ah,
I don't,
I don't even remember the process leading up to it.
No,
I think I was in a high time of like,
I'm just going to do whatever.
I was like starting to tour and do my own,
like DIY shit,
and then if stuff came around I was like,
oh,
that's cool.
All right,
I'll do the half hour.
And then I was kind of a,
not unappreciative,
but I may like nobody.
Did it change anything for you?
Watched him now?
I don't know.
Because then you look at the collection of your career,
like where you were then,
where you are now.
So who knows?
He knows
which one of those things.
That's true.
Led to the next thing.
I'm glad I got to do it,
but nobody saw those.
You like it.
You said it was miserable.
Well,
no,
it wasn't.
No,
that wasn't miserable.
It was just you got one taping.
Oh my God,
we didn't get to tapings.
And then when it's your first big TV thing,
like now I know that,
oh,
I screwed that up.
I'll do it again.
And I just tape it again.
And I tell the audience like,
just don't worry,
I got this.
You'll laugh again cause I screwed up the words and it's fun.
And this was the first thing we,
everything's gotta be perfect.
But then you didn't know how to settle in to the crowd because they're taping.
It has to be,
everything has to be perfect and it just,
it's fucking nerve,
right?
Yeah.
It was more not knowing how to deal with it.
I,
that's why I thought we did it with full Ciaran.
Yeah.
Full Toronto is putting it in the booth and full Toronto was putting his own
commercial breaks into a special and it was one of the funniest things I've ever
seen because I'm there with the people that are in them,
like looking at the monitors,
everything.
And he would just finish a joke and go,
we'll be right back.
And they're sitting there going,
how does he know where we're going to
pause it goes and we're back anyway.
His diet,
he can't,
he doesn't know what we're going to put the had full
charges.
That's still one of the funniest that tickles me the most.
That will cause,
oh here's this,
here's a fart story in a comedy story.
So you're about,
um,
did you ever do the laugh riots contest?
You remember that early?
I didn't do them but I have variety.
It was,
it was like a regional standup competition that comedy central heads.
So like the Midwest would have one and then you'd submit and they'd get 10
people to do that.
Like the Chicago's agonies and the winner from that.
And then the winner from the Texas one,
they'd have 10 of them in the 10 winners.
The finalists would come to la for to do a show.
And I wanted in Chicago and I was already planning on moving to La.
But then when I went that regional thing,
I'm like well here I come show Biz.
You don't even buy me a plane ticket cause I'm moving there.
And I did.
And cause that you could get on premium blend.
That was,
that was the first step.
Remember before half hours for sure it was premium blends.
And they were saying the top three people,
top three winners of the laugh riots would get a premium blend spot.
Well,
I did so bad on that show.
I know I came in dead last because not only do the top three winners,
nine people got on.
Yeah,
unblend from that show except for me.
And I bombed so bad.
And then I got,
I just drank all the free drinks I could backstage until the venue closed down
and I had just moved to la like a week before and I didn't,
I was like,
my friends were at some bar and I was just alone at the key club on sunset strip
at some stage hands,
a lady stage hand.
But like overall it's like a real tough gal.
She's like,
I'll give you a ride.
And she had gotten around to civic and she stopped at a norms to buy coke first.
So,
so we're in [inaudible] we're always open norms.
Yes.
We never close.
We never close norms when Denny's is a little too fancy for Denny's but with
open to a lot of open toed sandals.
So we stopped with the norms parking lot to,
to buy coke and she like,
she was a bigger girl so she had to hoist herself up out of her civic to go to
the other car to buy drugs and she just beefed like just like demo rock for just
brown.
And I was,
I was already drunk and she just goes,
whoops.
Like no shame.
Just whoops.
And then shut the door.
Just hot.
The drunk failure like another end up sitting there just like in her stink.
Oh,
I've failure.
She got back in the car and gave me like a,
a seal,
like a folded up magazine pages.
I hear,
let's Party and I open it up.
It was still like a bunch of like big,
it wasn't cracked,
but it was like big rocks.
And I'm like,
shouldn't we chop this up?
She's like,
yeah,
if you're a pussy.
And so I just tried to snort these big chunks of coke and they just went up my
nose.
It fell out on my shirt and I was like,
I left my family and friends,
I left,
I left my loved ones to pursue this dream.
And it was like a week of being here.
I was like,
you're not gonna make it.
You're not cut out for this.
And she dropped me off at the bar and my friends were at the front.
They're like,
Kyle,
I'm like not now.
And I ran in the bathroom cause then she came in looking for me like fuck,
like the,
the,
what was the,
was that the big foot that was putting like I'm going to put your little ears
came stopping and looking for me.
When you bombed that w did you know,
was it like out of the gate bomb where he like opened and you're like,
ah shit.
Yeah cause it was,
it was like,
it,
like Jamie Kennedy hosted it and he was drunk before the show even started.
So he was like screwing up people's names and then like the p like you could
tell who the favorite,
like the intown favorite was.
And again,
I get in my head before I ever do a set and you could tell the crowd was kind of
checking out already,
like talking to each other and I'm like,
here's my pro.
I didn't know how to hang out.
I was just like,
here's the bits that got me here and I'm going to say them how old they're
supposed to be said with no finesse or like relaxing into it and it was just
like,
I'm there and I'm done.
Okay,
well yeah.
Yeah.
Painful.
At least you got a premium blend I think.
No,
I never got,
I didn't get it.
Sorry.
Yeah,
I got the laugh riots part.
That's what I got filmed.
Less horrible.
I'm just realizing Kyle is that I have known you for a million years,
but I've never seen you in daylight.
Like you're one of these people.
I've only ever seen
the light of day,
afternoon nap.
Voice doesn't make me sound like I'm living.
Well,
all messages sent to me where they're like,
it's so weird to get like on Twitter or there'll be like,
do you look like you should have Kyle kinane is voice not your shitty voice?
Cool.
Thanks man,
isn't it?
Isn't it
so fun?
We'll be like,
your voice sucks.
You should have is his voice.
Well,
I don't know how like I'm not built for it like you guys and all the fat jokes
and I've just opened the world of inside jokes up to everyone.
I don't like any of that stuff.
When somebody like,
I'll shave my beard,
like this is pretty short,
but I'll shave it off.
And so many people just strangers or like,
hey,
you know how you normally have a beard?
Yeah,
you should grow that back right away.
I'm like,
just tell me my face is ugly.
That's what you're saying.
I sent you a picture of my face.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And I know what it looks like.
But the fact that people just like,
Hey,
your face,
it's bad.
So now I feel bad for him.
You should cover.
He's just trying to have fun though,
you know.
But you're a friend.
Okay.
This is just,
I'm saying strangers show the other night and somebody just,
cause I had worked with Burt before,
like minute bursts,
fat.
My man,
I'm
not part of that shit.
I Dunno.
I'm not part,
we're all fat now.
He is,
but he's the best.
He's the most racist,
racist.
Oh phew.
And believe it's a fun Bert.
Fun.
Burt dropping f bombs.
Fun Bird of the claim.
Or you get a sound bite?
I do.
I have it somewhere.
Oh yeah,
Bert dropping stuff.
Oh yeah.
Oh my gosh.
I didn't realize we had footage from his latest special you to record before
this starts going.
No,
no,
no.
Got All this black male shit on me.
I said before we start,
that would have been,
by the way,
Kyle,
can you know the r word,
the n word,
the c word.
Well,
I can't find it right
in front of it.
I'll say it.
I wonder if it's on the master list.
Is the bird thing on there?
Do you know if that's on there?
Uh,
he says he doesn't think so.
Oh,
of course not.
Let's see.
Let's see that.
No,
I don't have it.
Okay,
well,
what were you gonna say?
Third is the most racist track comedian.
Oh,
there he is right there.
Just admitting to it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I have him saying something super racist,
but he was on our show like knowingly saying it,
remember?
Oh really?
Yeah.
Well there was that time he would,
he set that Asian family on fire,
but there was a time that he,
uh,
I forget anyways.
Um,
I'll find it,
I'll find it at some point.
But anyway,
yeah,
it was never part of that whole see,
but people just tell me like,
you're a comedian,
Burt's fat.
I'm like,
all right man.
Yeah,
I guess,
but if you had it going with you and like one of your close friends and you guys
were endorsing it,
you know,
then people
shaved my face and my friend's like,
man,
your face is fucking terrible.
I'm like,
hi,
you're my friend.
But like a strangers like your face is ugly.
No,
it's drop dead.
Bury yourself and take your mother with
those east coast radio guys.
Guys came up as well.
Some other comics
glasses guy with glasses.
What are you the guys with glasses crew?
You must be a New York comic
mango.
These guys can't get enough of that kind of insight.
That makes me so nervous.
I get very uncomfortable listening to those kinds of shows.
For me,
I don't listen to any podcasts about comedy.
Oh wait,
I don't want to lie.
I don't let it come into,
I want to keep myself pier and watch any comedy.
I'm amazed when someone was like watching comedies drop in on like like new
special,
but then I'm watching it just to hate it and I'm like,
that's not the way to go about it is how it is.
Right?
Yeah.
I watch sky.
I been watching the Americans.
I don't watch it.
That right.
That's my point.
Funny at all.
No,
but when you're a comic though and you're around this all day and you're writing
and you're performing,
you're seeing it.
You want to be entertained.
I knew the other side.
Yeah.
The same reason people are at comedy shows because their lives are boring or
traumatic all the time,
but you need to laugh.
Right.
I'm like,
I've left plenty.
Yeah.
I need some real dry meetings.
I need something to make me cringe.
Same way I need to drop into somebody's real life that has like connected
relationships,
sir.
You just come home at 5:00 PM and have a meal.
You don't try and squelch the boredom with drugs or alcohol.
See a therapist twice a week.
I do have,
my friends are,
I'm Mike.
So you just go to bed at 10 yeah.
Bed.
You wake up and do shit in the morning time.
Yeah.
Even Rachel,
my girlfriend's like up.
I'm like,
wow.
All right,
well good luck with this part of the day.
Yeah,
well you at noon.
We used to sleep in until noon and then we had children and now like I'm up at
6:00 AM every day.
It's brutal.
Like it took three years for me to get used to that schedule because my normal
is nocturnal.
He and I used to be up till two three in the morning and then,
yeah.
But I don't want to,
every fucking shit's over.
You ever live your lives now and knowing that your kids could go through the
archives?
It's not an,
it's not a good thing to think about.
And it's definitely got a library.
Like I really wonder if like kids that can be like,
and not to pile on the Louis,
they budget budgeted.
Look,
my kids are assholes and like you laugh at it.
But then eventually those kids would be like,
he call us assholes to strangers.
I,
I do,
I do jokes about my folks.
I don't think their main,
but even after the show I have to ask my parents like,
it wasn't mean was it?
Yeah.
Oh,
I'm doing,
I'm,
I'm at this point now where I'm like,
Hey,
mom,
uh,
is really mean.
Well really?
Yeah.
And I'm like,
it's really mean,
but like,
it's helping your son,
you know,
and,
and provide for his family.
And she's like,
do you,
do you do that from the Bluetooth in your Blue Porsche?
Put food on the table.
Hold on.
I got down shift.
That's going be noisy.
Open it up in this car.
Pool Lane.
Accurate.
I can't to,
I won't tell my Bob
like how much I make or anything,
but she,
she's always asking me like,
how,
but how was,
how are your bills?
I'm like,
I'm fine.
I know it doesn't make sense that I tell jokes and I'm fine,
but you know,
but the mean stuff,
I'm like,
look at how much everybody else left.
My family
is so dysfunctional that I actually do have family members that won't speak to
me because of stuff that I've set on this show or am I act oh
yeah.
And it's kind of a favor.
It's a blessing in disguise.
Face time with my mom and show her cash.
You're like a rapper.
Yeah.
Yes.
And then she would hold it on your muscles.
It's not how you hold money.
Like I got another phone call,
hold on.
And then I'll send her a gift and she'll be like,
Ooh,
like what is this?
And it will be a mug with her face asleep in a picture on the mug.
She looks,
she looks dead.
We just made those.
She appreciate those gifts.
No,
no,
no.
I always cry.
Oh,
I don't want to make my mom cry.
Do you like your mom?
Yeah,
I mean I've argued with him,
but I like my parents.
My thing every year is every mother's Day I sent her flowers,
but the message only because I know the florist has to handwrite the message.
Like sometimes I do like hostage notes.
I've done like threats that's threatened her through it.
I'd be like,
me meet me with the money at the docks,
like to call it shit.
Just cause I know a stranger has to write that up in Dallas and she loves it.
Every year.
She's like,
I'm looking forward to mother's Day and I'm running out of ideas.
I'll just do a pick a language to put it in there.
That's really funny.
What about Valentine's Day?
Did you send her?
Does your mommy,
your valentines?
I talked to her today.
She said she,
she does send me Valentine's if I would live,
if I was in Chicago still I would still have to look for Easter basket.
She loves the holidays.
That's sweet.
She's a big fan.
She's a fun lady.
No,
that's nice.
I mean,
my mom's,
my mom was pretty nice,
but we always,
we've fucked with each other our whole life.
So I'm used to,
my mom was a bitch,
but she's dead.
Oh yeah.
Well that's,
well,
two out of three,
right guys?
Two out of three a.
We love our moms.
You know,
Christina's is a,
she was bad and she's done,
so.
Okay.
All right.
Hey,
okay,
cool.
6% motherly love comic guys.
Where's that come from?
That was
wow.
Dot.
Come back.
How's everybody else's career ruined?
And you have a studio for a podcast that would,
that kind of bullshit my shots world toward it's on sale now.
Go see Burton checkout.
Are you guys there?
He got a bookcase.
Kinda Shanana.
It's a really crazy actually.
Um,
ah,
what did I have for you?
Oh,
you know what I found?
I couldn't find a course.
I can never find anything.
But I found,
remember we had big daddy Kane on.
Yeah.
And I was trying to tell him what is it?
Is it,
um,
in my asshole smells.
Have Jesus Christ pages to your girlfriend?
Yes.
Hold Mail.
How serious right now are you dating?
You were in a serious relationship committed.
She,
she's not a comedian.
No.
So she's a adjacent to the world.
Do you demand that she eats your scrum,
licks,
your scrum,
scrum or later,
have you ever asked for that?
Which parts of the scrum?
It's basically,
you're like you're raising cake,
you know,
look,
we're the,
we're the Duke he comes out of,
that's the reason cake I think so.
Sacred your balls.
We'll be raising kick cause they look raise in and they're like a little loaf.
I mean,
I'm up for the argument.
I think that's it.
And I thought I've stated you stated yours.
I mean,
no,
I don't need it.
Yeah,
I'll,
I'll dish it out,
but I don't need it.
I don't know.
I never want like she'll send me,
you seem like a guy that would demand it but keep going.
No.
Well that's the thing.
Like she'll send me Dick pics in there of my deck while I'm asleep and I never
wanted to see my body from that angle.
I've never wanted to see my,
my Dick and balls from the feet up.
Yeah.
That was like,
not only is it,
why not find it attractive?
What,
how,
what's wrong with you?
I'm glad,
but the fact that I would even have to know what my butthole would be like.
Ah,
right.
And plus your browns are messy or vegetarian?
No,
I'm pretty,
I'm pretty decent about that.
Sometimes comes out real clean after no squatty potty.
Squatty potty.
Just opening it up.
Your system pretty.
Are you pretty regular?
I Dunno what's regular,
you know what I mean?
Like once a day are you like,
what is it like twice a day?
Why is it the same time every morning kind of thing?
If I throw some coffee in there?
Yeah,
coffee I do.
I scare my girlfriend first because I would do this thing called like a Tongan
Death March when I'm just kind of slapping my stomach,
which is like,
what's going on?
I'm like,
I'm drumming up business and like truly thought that I was like getting it all
to fucking burger king down or been burger time down into the right position.
Oh,
yeah.
Yeah,
I'll do that.
I go camping a lot of like shitting outside you guys.
Yeah.
You guys talk about shit all the time.
Ever.
Shit outside.
You have a house with a yard now.
You can just do that.
I pee in the backyard.
Sometimes the people in the yard I peed in the back yard a few times.
I believe it or it did do it too because of a reason or just because we were
drinking in the back yard.
Well then yeah.
Yeah,
but I mean I'll do like dig a hole and will you do that in your own yard though?
I don't have a yard.
I live in an apartment,
but I mean if you had a yard,
go to the park.
The park or to the dog park.
Yeah,
that was my camping or something.
I'll go,
I'll do lab like mountain biking up in the woods and there.
All right,
we've got to do this here.
Yeah,
we've got to handle this business and you dig a hole and you and you squat in
the proper way that you should be.
That's the way,
the way you're supposed to do
it.
It feels like Turkish toilets or whatever,
like,
oh,
how could you do that?
But that's the best way.
That's how I,
yeah,
that's a way it opens it up.
Yeah,
I know.
So can you,
so she's,
but can you be yourself with our,
I guess,
I guess I don't understand how people,
like if you're not married,
a comedian,
like I just say what I want to him and were horrible to each other.
Yeah.
But I also don't get to censor yourself sometime.
No,
because that's not something I would talk about,
like my scrum.
That wouldn't,
it.
You're not,
you're not into that kind of dialogue with her.
You said that was so much to stand.
It's disgusting.
Right.
Kind of blessing.
He,
that's what he says to me all the time.
Built an empire on this.
But I'm mystified by that.
Yeah.
I mean,
yes,
laugh at it.
It's fucking ridiculous.
This is the studio that part's made.
You got to see this other car,
but,
but here,
let me just ask you this,
does this or something
you would do to your lady last night?
Tom Goes,
he like,
he,
he'll go make a brown,
he'll come back and he'll be like,
I have a great story for you.
I'd be like,
what?
He's like,
yeah,
he sat down and then I made a brown and then I flushed and I'm like,
that's not even a real story.
But he's,
he's always telling me nasty shit.
Are you nasty like that with your lady?
No.
Yeah.
I want to preserve.
Right.
So
you see her as a woman still?
Yeah.
Somebody sexually viable.
Yes.
She's a whole lady to me.
Yeah.
I'm not trying to cause a rift come here to start me.
It's been like this for 14 years.
So.
Well,
and what are you getting upset?
There you go.
Oh,
I did by the way.
14 years and now you're bringing it up,
bringing it up for the whole time.
Yesterday
I told her pretty cool story.
She made it sound like it was like really juvenile and they'd run it by me.
So I was in Reno and I was uh,
I was supposed to a good start.
Yeah.
I was supposed to take a ride back on the bus after the show Saturday night and
there was snow storms like you're flying out.
So I spend the night and I'm like kind of bummed about that bus tour bus.
So it had,
I had a tour bus take me.
Oh,
it was great.
I was like,
hell,
I thought you're doing well in my head.
I'm like,
Oh hey greyhound,
I still take that sounds so excited because the idea of the whole plan was
finished the show Saturday night and immediately get on a bus,
go to bed,
wake up at home.
I was like,
that's kind of the train.
Yeah.
So anyways,
they let me know like,
ah,
we can't do it anymore.
So you've got to fly out of Reno in the morning.
So I spend the night,
they're not happy about it.
Get up early,
get to the airport.
And I,
I was with,
uh,
Josh Potter.
I go,
Hey,
hold my bags and I,
you know,
which is the,
I was one of the best by the way.
Advantages of traveling with friends.
Yeah.
Was like you have to bring your bags.
That must be leaving the bags with somebody,
you know,
bowels free and clear
bathroom that you're caring about.
Decorating your closet.
I fucking hate that part.
And then I don't want to put stuff on the ground because you see peas.
I'm like,
I'm watching the coat hook bend with the weight of my and men's rooms.
Rosis there.
Of course.
I mean there's so filthy,
so I just go in
there and I got,
my handle is anyways,
I just let out a couple of crazy far,
nothing else comes out.
I get home,
right?
I fly,
I get home,
they,
the story gets more,
it gets better and then I go home and I am ready for now.
It's been a couple of hours.
I get home,
I sit down,
a couple other huge farts.
Then I fart in the kitchen and you're like,
hey,
take it easy.
There's people walking around.
We had a nanny helping us out and then,
and then,
uh,
and then I shit later.
And then that's the whole story.
Do you talk like this Tier Laney?
I don't think she'd be interested.
I wasn't either.
I think it's a pretty good story.
I think anybody that does not match the Reno start made itself in Reno.
Yeah.
Well maybe you guys aren't up on a storytelling,
but anyways,
um,
there's a
couple emails,
um,
people wrote in,
let's see here.
Oh,
this was like,
um,
I guess we discussed this on the last thing about our pronouns that um,
yeah,
Starbucks has a pronoun pins for the employees to wear him.
Hers,
them,
they,
you know,
you're up on your end of the day because that's plural.
Well,
[inaudible] got introduced as day and I'm like,
ah,
like a dual act and an interesting one po,
it was more of a grammar thing.
I have a kid now.
Did the person make the distinction to be introduced as day?
Oh,
it was.
Okay.
So they said like bringing,
yeah.
All right,
well I'm wondering if maybe I'm poly and by pins aren't far behind.
And then this person wrote,
burp,
Burp,
shy.
Zur is fat.
Okay.
Wow.
All right.
That's it.
That just keeps,
you wouldn't believe how much people love that shaming Bert.
It's really taken us shame if it doesn't care.
So good point.
That's a good point.
Who's that?
And he kind of enjoys the attention a little.
Yeah.
That it's not,
it's just fat.
A recognition.
That's true fat.
Yes.
No shame there.
I like this angle.
Thank you.
What's Your Pronoun?
What are you going by these days,
Kyle?
Oh yeah.
Fela.
Yeah.
I'm going to him.
You're him.
Yeah,
his,
oh,
it must be interesting to hear at Kyle's take on this because this is in
response to an earlier episode of Said,
Hey,
what's good?
So this bitch,
I work,
that's another fun thing on our show.
So this bitch
with poorly whistles old macdonald,
every single mother fucking day.
I had a vision punching her as hard as I can in the chest.
She also does,
she also does,
it says absurd shit.
You know how people said,
yeah,
uh,
say Shit.
If they make a mistake or something of that nature,
she will say cats are junkies to top it off and have boy to top it off,
she looks like an identical to Dwight Schrute from the office.
And that is from Nathan.
We were just talking about,
you know,
I think it's this kind of power,
power trip,
passive aggressive thing when you're,
you know,
maybe waiting in line at a coffee shop or somewhere and then there's some guy,
huh?
No public whistler Whistler's the word and it's the only thing that the better
you are at it,
the more obnoxious it is.
You want somebody to be like,
look how good I can whistle I hood rat.
I W I think now that the retaliation has to just shittily whistle something else
with that person and shit like chime in or just if somebody is whistling good
and you're like,
yeah,
I got you man.
You Buddy.
Yeah.
Pick a key.
All right.
Yeah,
no,
I agree that a public whistling a should be forbidden.
Yeah.
It was in the,
or even like,
you know,
it was,
it was in a gym locker room and it's like you're just,
obviously you're winding down,
you're going to get cleaned up.
And then there's a guy,
you know,
there's only like two or three of us in the,
in the locker room and he's just like a whistling the whole way through,
whistling to the shower,
whistling on the way back.
It's like,
all right man.
I think we all get it.
I try to be pretty tolerant of a lot of things will pug,
but that one's a tro,
shy won't.
Yeah,
it does.
I mean,
I don't know if this guy should a punch her in the chest,
but that's probably,
you know,
I see.
I understand is rich.
Yeah.
I want you also seems like he's got some other issues.
Wow.
That's
uh,
I think it was gene Pompa,
was it?
Or taught now?
Sorry.
Tom Papa on his Instagram the other day had a video of a guy,
a full grown man playing a video game at full volume on an airplane.
Like just how the iPad out at full volume.
Boop,
boop,
beep,
boop up like,
oh my fucking God,
what?
Yeah,
that's horrible.
I need ear about what to do.
Say stuff.
Yeah.
I'd say something at that point like,
Brooke,
can you,
my thing is the women are smoking.
It's that classic New York comedy.
Stupid fucking dumb bitch.
What'd you learn?
How to whisper the helicopter.
Go ahead.
But like at what point do you step it?
Like when the TV screens on the headrest.
Fuck your mom.
I know I'm going at it and that's where I like I'll give,
I'll give a look first.
Yeah.
Like a turn around.
Like,
you know my head's right,
the side of this
and then I'm just like,
hey man,
it's a touch screen,
right?
Yeah.
You just,
you just have to,
it's by the heat of your finger,
not the pressure.
Right,
right.
Hello?
Oh yeah.
I've had a bitch back in the day.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
And I've turned around,
but like,
could you,
could you please?
And she was like,
fuck you.
You Bitch.
Like she got mad at me.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
She's like,
fuck you.
I'll do what I want.
And I was like,
okay,
yeah,
I had to call over the flight attendants is years ago.
She was like hammering,
it was probably on your mom's house.
I brought it out and you turn it and you,
and I was like,
excuse me.
You know,
every time you do that I feel it.
Do you mind?
And she was like,
I'll do whatever I want.
Like she was sassing back to me and then I had to call a flight attendant.
I was like,
she's kind of crazy.
Have you retaliatory farden like give you yes,
I have like just fart interface.
Uh,
none of that time.
But I have farted when people next to me,
we're being very annoying.
Yeah.
And then I fart.
You do that too.
I'm like a skunk.
I'm getting defensive.
She also did it.
She also did it to somebody who didn't do anything wrong.
And then the lady was like,
smells like a dirty diaper in here.
Like,
because Christina was kind of lady was not smart.
I'm going to go.
That was it.
An accent from a country Wa was bad.
Here
you don't learn that accent.
He retarded.
That's not a regional,
it's because of this.
A lot of women out there fully fucking full of shit and it's stupid.
What do you think?
How would you say 90 or lady?
No,
no,
no.
I would definitely take like this.
Let me tell you,
Kelly,
I live with a small amount of fear every day and I like,
really,
I'm happy for that.
From,
from your lady?
Yeah.
Really well,
it's talking about it.
What are you afraid of?
Like what,
how does she remember me?
And you know,
no,
I get a bad way.
But like,
pounce,
keep you in check.
Like flinch me.
Make me Flinch.
Huh?
Yeah.
It's a lot.
There's a lot of that.
Really.
Yeah.
I love it.
It's very attractive.
Yeah.
You apologize a lot for no reason.
Well,
no sir.
I was,
I was screwing around.
I love it.
Yeah,
you would like my toes.
I think he would like,
um,
hard rock nick.
Oh,
for God's sake.
It was hard rock,
man.
This dude's dues.
Bad Ass.
So that's sounds like it.
Yeah.
Like,
do you ever wear pink?
Big Fan of him embroidered satin jackets?
Uh,
you were everywhere pink or you like somebody comfortable with that?
Yeah.
You do,
man.
I don't have a lot.
I don't have,
I have a couple shirts.
Well,
all right,
well there's a couple of guys that were like,
like,
oh,
was that a real guy?
Yeah.
What's up this question a lot.
That's not a real guy.
Why do I wear pink so much?
I wear pink because I like pink pussies.
You know,
like inside.
I like to actually spread the pussy lips all been while I'm packing missionary.
That shit's hot.
And the other reason I like pink or wear pink is because if you look at all the
richest men in the world,
which I'm one of,
I have 20 million in the bank.
No bullshit.
Google it suck on my fucking testes.
Google all the richest men in the world where Pant 50 sat wears pink Tom Cruise.
Whereas paint Simon Rex fucking wears pink condoms.
So that's what it is.
20 million in the bank and fucking growing.
You don't need heroin.
You're this good looking baby
real.
I refuse to believe that.
Like now that had been kind of like that's a character I think is right.
Here's the thing,
if it was just this video,
I'd be like,
this dude's fucking savage.
But like committing that fucking etch a sketch,
goatee and shit.
Yeah,
there's more.
That's like the,
yeah,
that's like the Mr Fuzzy math.
But I just don't you think you're just kind of hating on him cause he's so
successful and he's got pink shirts.
I mean I appreciate his humility.
This is him.
How many people we got in here?
Not even 400 man.
The artwork,
there wasn't $30 but thank you.
This is one piece of artwork.
I mean y'all don't want to comment on the fact that I'm sitting in $1,000 custom
movie theater chair and I have five of them.
I mean retarded man.
This,
all these people under good,
you know,
movie theater seats are all five.
That's a dollar.
That's my movie.
Tickets are so much I got to pay for it
all is people under 35 what's wrong with you guys?
Why are you so angry?
Bitter?
Was it nine 11 natal vitamins?
Then you guys felt robbed of your youth.
Was it Columbine?
Was it all these mass shootings that you guys got terror struck in you from your
media and mom and dad?
I'm like,
what the fuck?
I was happy when people got rich.
I'm still happy when people get rich on a game show or from winning the lottery
or from winning American idol or from success or a comeback like,
oh my God,
this is just the retardation of your generation.
Awesome.
He used to Amazon deliveries a week.
Now it's one.
Go ahead.
No,
the other way.
Oh,
you're right.
You're right.
It used to be to what is hardcore.
Nick's a backstory.
Excuse me.
It's hard rock nick.
Well,
it's funny.
You know what you could do or do you pull up his bio,
his bio that had a little info on the bio really lays it out and it's,
um,
what it's going to make you do is probably rewrite your own bio if you don't
mind.
Need to.
Anyway,
so that's what I'm saying.
So could you read his bio out loud?
It's right there.
That's his bio.
He looks like a rape genie.
Will you let it?
You let it rip.
You don't get no witches,
but I'm out now.
I'll give you something to wish
so it's,
it's in a caption.
All right,
so he posted that picture.
Go ahead.
On my 12th Mercedes Benz like,
like as a hot dog eating contest.
Yeah.
I'm on my 12th one that keep fucking these things up.
Born in Las Vegas.
You could stop there.
That's got a lot of houses.
Where does you usually shop?
Doe over $30,000 a tattoos on my body.
Easily shops at Bristol farms.
Oh,
okay.
Average one Amazon.
What does that have to do this?
He shows you he's always shopping bro.
How many packages a week you get bitch.
Yeah.
How many but I going to say what cow but without seeing what he gets
10 pack toothbrushes from Amazon.
That's my pack.
Just week worth of good,
good.
Three 50 350 million.
That kind of house I live in prefer eating pussy from the bath.
Okay.
Love.
And I mean love getting mud deck so it feels good.
Almost 300 pounds.
But carry it like I'm 210 pounds.
What is specific?
No,
I didn't want to go 200 cause that's like,
that's too obvious to 10 that's true.
I'm thinking about Alexa,
the shit out of my house.
Yeah.
He's got a lot of Alexis.
He's got a lot of,
you know what I mean?
That's some,
that's when you want to stunt on your guests.
Be like,
check out all these Alexis.
I got,
Hey Alexa,
and then you just,
but Alexa doesn't understand half the shit you say to her.
Anyway.
Alexa,
keep Alexa company.
All right.
This is,
this is where the AI meltdown starts as this guy's house.
If it's true.
That's how the robots learn to communicate with one another to defeat the
humans.
That's where I go with it.
Like this guy is going to be the cause of it.
Look at his eyelashes.
What he cares.
Firms
care for himself.
Why you hate him.
I just said he cares for him,
so okay.
Okay.
I just wanted to make sure there was no misunderstanding.
He looks like those look like fake lashes.
I think this guy does throw a little bit on the makeup and everything.
I think he's got it.
He's like rich and crazy,
but then messes around with some may really think he's rich.
That's our mother fucking hate.
Oh,
that's him.
And he finance for white girls.
Well that's another thing.
He's also racist.
He didn't love him.
Now if he didn't love him before,
I mean now you're really going to,
can you read this loud?
Uh,
Kyle,
right?
Okay ladies.
Yeah.
If you have an ass like this and our pure white American born female,
not mixed with Mexican or Israeli and Shit,
have light eyes and a career and we'll let me put my face in it.
Every time you bend over the sink to do your makeup,
get at me.
I wish you would read all this guy.
Looks like he's whatever ethnicity genies are from and he's going to say no
Mexican or Israeli.
Every Jeannie is Mexicans railing.
Yeah,
I think you're right.
It's always like a Mexican Israeli flag.
This is like a self hate.
Always Mexican Israeli,
you know,
you know that's how they work.
That's how,
how about this,
Oh boy,
the 10 turn offs and a woman in order of level of turn off
number one non Caucasian,
right?
I mean you gotta know what you want in this world.
What do you like smoke or have any kind of vegetarian wears too much makeup,
wears perfume from Walmart or Tj Maxx,
et cetera.
Never says thank you.
Oh see look,
he likes it.
Pilliga prudish sexually as visible facial hair.
Even Peach Fuzz as a child from a previous man.
Won't shop.
Eat,
do yoga anywhere unless she has a coupon.
Groupon magazine clipping.
There you go.
All right.
Now this is from 2012
he may have a ball.
Have we checked up on Nicholas' rack?
Johanson Shroud?
I don't know.
No,
We haven't seen those photos in the livestream.
All recent current.
But this is a very specific list cause he contacted you guys.
Is he come around the beach?
No,
no,
no.
Really.
You don't want to hard rock nick around here.
I mean you're both white.
Well it'd be cool with it.
You know what I realized is that,
well blue band is,
is uh,
he's already mixing up.
Just qualified from the running for it.
Yeah.
I got some Jewish Israeli blooded take a hike.
Yup.
Fuzz
face.
Do you like being eaten out from the back will come at you?
Human Centipede Style
and I'm also not American born and I'm old as fuck for him to blow your side.
Definitely not
for me.
I'm just going to look at,
cause I know we're going to be bros immediately.
Like he'll see me and be like similar.
Look,
you seem to get your eyebrows dark
beard.
Beard.
We're sculpting.
Get like a detailer.
A hard
rock.
Nick's beard.
Oh Man.
I would love for you to do then you Halloween people,
right?
I Dunno,
but man if it was September right now,
pretty bad ass.
I'd be like,
I'm hard rock.
People just think you're making a,
making fun of any Armenian.
And you said Armenian Armenian
or Armenian?
Nicholas Rock.
Johansen bullshit.
That is a matter of
middle names.
Rock Nicholas.
No,
no.
This guy's either Persian.
Armenian.
Yeah.
They're proud of their wealth.
Look at the bright side.
$350 million.
Didn't say how he made it,
right?
No.
Well I mean,
you know,
obviously entrepreneur online poker,
poker would definitely fit.
He's got online poker vibe for sure.
Regular Poker vibe.
I was always fascinated with the confident nerds of poker championship,
of just the swagger of a,
of a pope and classes also like all the looks that are like you turds,
can you,
are you in?
Are you,
do you like poker?
No,
I've never been into it and what really blew my mind was when it became
televise.
I'm like motherfuckers on his watching this bullshit.
That was well that's what would drive me nuts.
It's like,
you know Matt Brown and I used to do closed captioning for living.
Dan was what we do for t for our day jobs and we'd have to close caption all
those poker tournaments.
It's the most infuriating,
like just listening to your playing cards.
I wouldn't want to stand around watching you play cards,
let alone have to type out all the words they're saying it's a three nuts on the
flop and the river.
I'm like,
this is
terrible.
And everybody's got their own interests.
But I go to Vegas and I play the war.
I'll play like roulette,
which is the worst odds,
but I can't fuck him anything other than playing it.
Yeah.
Poker,
blackjack.
I could screw something up and then I lost because I was done.
But the thing about blackjack too,
fun spinning,
Spinning wheels,
fun blackjack.
You can fuck it up for other people.
Well that's fun.
Yeah.
Well it's also,
but it's also the thing I've seen people be like,
are you fucking serious?
We're going to hit on,
you know,
like people get really fired up on those uh,
blackjack and I don't understand at all.
I don't think anybody does.
I think that's how craps exists is nobody knows what they're doing.
And also throw down a 20 on the high hand.
Let me get a low hook on the Yoyo.
I was in Reno where I had done a show and didn't do great and then I was kind of
shuffled around the casino and these kind of grizzled mountain full or there and
they're like,
you a real funny man.
Play craps with us.
It was like,
all right,
and I like,
I lost 10 bucks and I'm like,
I don't have any more money.
It's like,
don't worry,
man.
Gave me 100 bucks.
I was like,
wow.
I'm like,
hey man,
I want to take your money.
He's like,
don't worry about it,
man.
We grilled.
He just kept and he kept touching the table and the lady would have to step and
be like,
don't touch the table as well.
We'll,
sorry ma'am.
These old pot farmers throwing all their money on just grabbing shit off the
table,
get yelled at.
It was a good time.
That's fun though.
Nobody knew what they were doing,
but it would be fun.
I've played craps twice with seasoned the players an hour with each of them.
I was like,
I have no idea who the fuck's going on.
It's still luck.
Yeah,
it's luck.
It's all last time I played craps,
I was at,
I was in Vegas and I went to go see rock of ages by myself because I,
you know,
oh,
hang out.
I don't care.
Rock of ages,
the musical about the sunset strip,
eighties rock music.
And that was that.
I was one of maybe 40 people in the entire amphitheater and I was singing along
and clapping and crying at the sentimental part.
Yeah.
And then the woman next to me who kept kind of spilling my beer,
uh,
she give me 20 bucks as we walked out cause she,
I guess I look like my wife just left me or something cause I was getting way
too.
I was getting way too in a rock of ages by myself and she's like,
I'm sorry for dinner.
Here you go honey.
I'm like,
I'm actually have a great time.
You don't have to do this.
She's like,
no,
no.
You take this 20 bucks.
And I blew it on the craps table.
Sweet though.
I guess I looked pretty bad shape.
Yeah,
I guess I look like a real sad dude having fun.
No.
Have you had that,
cause I know you're real,
Christina is very sensitive to the idea of food or drinks being expired and to
the point of like,
Hey,
this is from Monday and it's Wednesday.
She's like,
oh,
it's from Monday.
How that's trading.
I've been working off Manet's from 27 that's what I'm talking about right there.
Canadian doesn't fuck around.
I know he went,
I'm,
I'm the women are fucking stupid.
He's still the bitch.
Play the clip.
I did see the
buyer's March 20th,
2014 it doesn't do sweet.
I'm sorry we can't help you.
There's no refunds.
You need funds.
I want another juice.
Isn't that sweet?
Give me,
give me three shifts.
We do.
What did they get started?
[inaudible] expired.
I didn't believe these numbers.
All the company complained to them.
We put them over not replacing it.
What company?
So company.
Okay,
you can leave now,
right?
So company take guys.
Fats,
fats.
Take your juicing goal.
What should they,
can they just give me sweet juice?
Okay.
Gold Leaf.
Like call the cops.
Oh,
coffee cups.
Okay,
just kidding you.
You can just give him a car.
My mom,
my mom would do,
I'm not even lying you fucking cunt.
She's had a fucking car,
right?
Did my mother say fucking cut in front of you the first time she met you?
Yeah.
This fucking can't.
This is not sweet.
That's how crazy she was.
And then this is totally an immigrant thing too.
Like how she's pointing to the Jews.
This is not fucking,
oh yeah.
This is not
your fucking can't just check can be related to me Bro.
You said I hate fat.
Pigman yeah,
it's gotta be
language.
There's somebody taught her swear go wrong way.
Oh right.
Just trying to say like cock suckers.
[inaudible]
not helping your argument here.
I mean she's Kinda heavy herself though.
I mean the fan forum,
I mean she carries it like it's two 10 though.
This tooth is really gives you the illusion of slimming.
The illusion.
Oh,
she's just crying and
get the juice is sweeter.
It's Tropicana.
They should so sweet dude.
It's nothing but sugar.
No fucking country.
You know,
she's smoking four packs a day.
Taste buds.
That's why she kicked
Fatso company.
That's my favorite one.
It's a company that somebody like production card.
Could you imagine this person raising you?
This is actually my mom.
This is literally,
it's a lot.
It is a lot of she main lady.
Yeah.
She was crazy though.
But those are the kind of shit you would do to like fucking bitch and then she
would get mad at people for seeding her too close to the toilet at restaurants.
She get real racist too,
like these fucking,
Oh God,
oh no
Vietnamese restaurant.
We went to Sushi.
It was a Japanese
in the ballpark but then to the ladies just like,
can I get you guys into their drinks?
He's like,
you know what you did,
you're fucking crazy
angry.
I saw my mom freak out once but it was only on my behalf.
Then it like wasn't racist or anything like I bought the wrong,
I was like a little kid at Bros by and I thought I was buying like a model
garage for model cars,
but it turned out to be like the little
figures and I couldn't even see the counter that says no returns on it at the
hobby shop and saw my mom like the guy wouldn't give me my money back.
It's my mom went there.
It was like my son can't even see your no return sign.
He thought it was nothing's broken.
He just took the plastic off and the guy wouldn't do it.
So my mom just sat there and anybody walk in,
don't touch anything.
This guy,
I won't give you refunds.
And then had to call mall security and now my mom's about to get arrested flow,
but she's standing up.
She's like,
I'm doing this for you.
I'm like,
please stop.
Please stop it.
Classmates are here and they see you now being talked to by mall security
because you're harassing all customers in Italy.
Shutdowns,
toys and hobbies.
But she was like,
she's a righteous lady.
She is a righteous lamps.
They,
it wasn't talked to her today.
Yeah,
I got one sister older or younger?
Younger.
She lives here.
She moved down here a little while.
How long ago?
A year and a half ago.
You get to see each other a lot and we hang out and we're good.
That's cool.
Family Salad,
you know?
Yeah.
What's,
yeah,
like I got nothing.
You know what my mom used to do?
That was really funny.
When we would go to the mall
department store and I used a company.
Your mom so you know,
she has like olive skin and she has this heavy accent and everybody would always
be like,
where are you from?
And so she would always say,
guess and then so they would be a,
you know,
a lot of times with Russian and not,
not once or twice a number of times when I was with her they would go,
they would go,
they would like talk because she would say a,
you know,
I went to buy the blah blah blah.
And they would be like,
do you speak to,
are you Chinese?
And my mom would go yes.
And then,
and they would go say something in Chinese,
like just,
just like a lady will work in the makeup counter and my mom would go,
she was my time and then they would go like,
whoa.
And then she would just look at me and say she was off out and I'd be like,
she's looking for makeup remover.
And they were like,
that's so cool that your mom speaks Chinese.
And I'm like,
you know it dip shit.
Yeah,
that bagger grocery bagger.
Go ahead.
No,
you tell you tell him.
I did.
I look at you too,
sweetheart.
I used to do this all the time where like
I did two things like bread,
a stoplight and uh,
somebody crossing the street who had clearly is a disabled,
like walking with it.
Sure.
I would go,
uh,
just to my mom,
cause I knew I would get her.
I'd be like,
okay,
this guy,
I'll drunk 10 o'clock in the morning and she would be like,
what?
She's like,
he a problem.
I was like,
yeah,
he's a drunk and I just drive off.
And then at the grocery store they have a grocery store near them that we'll
hire like a special needs people.
So just to mess with her,
I would,
um,
like they
bag and
bag it up
and then take it to the car.
And then like a guy would put it in the car and that's what that was the job.
And then as he walked away,
I would just look at her real seriously.
An ideal.
I think something's wrong with that guy.
She,
she didn't know what
is wrong with that,
but she was like,
yes,
no,
you're good.
Cool.
No,
it's fun to have a foreign parent toy with.
But she also doesn't know like that.
Even now the r word is not desirable to say.
And um,
and I've heard her say it in front of people like in a casual setting and I'm
like,
yeah,
you could see people's face be like,
Whoa,
this is a 70 year old lady and really throwing that cause it's like it's a,
you know,
it's still like foreign language to her.
You know,
people have like me and I understand we're not supposed to say all that stuff,
but the over sensitivity to it,
like older people who are immigrant and foreign,
like English isn't their first language.
Like they don't have the same sensitivity.
Yeah.
I heard that defensive like,
like somebody in Europe using the n word,
like they're not using it racist.
They're using it.
Cause I grew up listening to hip hop and that was like a punctuated throughout
that.
So they don't have like the historical context that you have here in this
country that just say it because they pop bars,
it doesn't make it right,
but the awareness is there.
I would feel I would agree with that.
I feel like that generated like people,
like we grew up saying words that I'm like,
I can't believe like how often you would just say faggot or something as a plan
now it's like,
yeah,
I would not do that.
I know now and it's not like PC culture says no,
I know that word.
It's Shitty.
That was it.
And I think like my parents and our parents' generation was that,
that with some other words and then when they learn that you can't say that
anymore.
It became this like kind of forbidden thing.
It totally
like if Brazil nuts showed up in my house,
they showed up because somebody needed a fix.
So
you know,
we used to call these,
I'm like,
yes.
Yes,
you'd say it every time Brazil nuts are in the house.
Yeah,
that one I never got by it away.
Well my mom would say it with shame.
Can you not going to believe what we used to call these?
I'm like,
I will believe it.
Because you say that every time you see a Brazil nut.
Yeah.
Like you're scratching an itch right now.
Not because I think it'll,
well it's just the physical composing of making the word that you can't anymore.
Yeah,
because,
because the taboo,
it feels like a day or two.
You know,
like the,
the further case for the,
the English as a second language person is that some of those words just don't
have that same impact in their minds.
You know,
that it has on ours tax was never there,
never there.
And it sounds like if I told you,
you know,
whatever you do,
don't say Bozeman when you're around these people,
you're going to be like,
okay,
like you know it,
but you're like,
it doesn't hurt.
And when I say it,
but also like don't say it,
you're like,
hmm.
Yeah,
like my cousin about elephants,
Shit.
My cousins used to come over and drop everything.
Like everything was like,
don't ever say these six words.
They'd be,
like I say,
it's right now.
And like,
they'll say it,
it's like,
uh,
the fag thing,
which was so like,
you know,
throwing that around in middle school and a lot,
dude,
they came for Thanksgiving and I meet them at a,
I haven't seen some of them in 10 years and as I walk into a restaurant,
but these are 35,
36 year old man.
They go,
fuck God that was there.
Hello.
There's no,
no,
don't do it.
Like where are they from?
Peru.
Okay.
Yeah,
I mean they have like a heavy act,
like their English isn't,
we're just like,
I remembered the words were not supposed to say,
but I think also like the generation,
I don't think it's just foreign parents.
Like
what you can do with humor.
It's like my mom,
like,
like when your kid,
when you find out your kids are actually funny on their own,
right.
Like I think my mom would encourage a little bit like me and my sister,
the student driver cars would come by our house and so we would always crash our
bikes right behind like Duke,
some solid over the bars,
Prat.
So they were just like a student driver would see in the rear view mirror,
bike fly up and then a kid just laying there and I'm like,
I'd run up to my sister like,
are you okay if my mom would be in the house laughing her ass off and she'd be
like,
you guys shouldn't do that.
It's real funny.
Would reprimand us but not hard enough to be like,
if it comes round again,
I got to get your dad to watch too.
It was pretty funny.
Well that's a struggle we have with,
uh,
with our three year old is that now he's starting to say shit like he's learning
to burp and fart and that's like
that.
And we also tell them nobody discourage any burp.
It's one thumbs up if it's foreign,
it's two thumbs up.
And then we're like,
ah,
raise just cave piece savages like this,
this you've years of documentation then that's what,
I can't imagine it like trying to raise a kid and they're going to have a sample
board like that of everything you've said.
Like,
Oh really?
Were you guys farted in the microphones?
I can't do what?
Well,
it says differently.
He also got no cards anymore.
He learns that if the doorbell rings,
that means off.
Fuck
true.
It's got a world of hurt
because I,
that was my natural to the doorbell ringing just cause like I was comfortable.
So you heard and I was like,
oh fuck.
As soon as I did it he was like fuck.
Like just looked right at me.
Here we go.
Shit,
somebody got a new favorite word.
I don't discourage
picking either.
I can't,
I mean I still
do you feel like it's Elementary Watch for picking the yeah,
we'll get in there.
Yeah,
that was a bad thing when my girlfriend,
when we live separately and I'd be at her house and then she was like moving
stuff around and she's like a Frederick booger grave.
Ah,
you don't know how many of you are putting down there until one day somebody
moves the bed,
pick my nose and wipe him on the back of a couch when I was like in high school
and one time they,
there was some repair and that needed to be done on that couch.
I never thought of that.
The guy comes to service,
it moves the couch and there's just dried.
Okay.
That's how I watch my one friend freaking another for like first friend who like
at his own place,
like at a townhouse were over there.
My Buddy Bob's just going at it and finally my friend Jessie ended off,
he's like,
stop picking your fucking nose music.
What are you curious?
Cause you don't just pick your nose,
you pick your nose and then you wipe that shit on my stuff.
You put net booger on my couch.
I'm sick of finding your boogers on my fucking couch and we're all so high like
get over itself man.
It was the funniest thing to see it.
Like we're on the level,
we're just fucking party dudes.
And somebody finally freaked out about having a buggery couch like,
well great,
well look who's grown up.
I don't want his friends bloggers all over stuff
in your fridge and close the door real quick.
Hope,
hope your food tastes like,
well I think it's gross to have the designated area.
He
knows and then he'll roll and just throw them on.
The floor
subconscious
like on an airplane,
just go and,
and then you don't,
you don't realize like,
Oh shit,
the deepest,
I just absolute most impressive deep dig I've ever seen in public.
Was Christopher Lloyd on a plane?
Yeah.
I sat next to me and he did a full cleaning each sailor,
each nostril and the second knuckle.
Oh yeah.
And I did a full swirl and I was like,
he didn't give a fuck.
It was like,
it was partially like,
I wanted to think,
he was like,
do you know what the fuck I am?
Like,
I wish it was that.
And it was partially,
I think age too.
He's like,
I'm not getting up to bathroom cleaner
towards the defense mechanism.
Like,
Hey,
are you critical blood?
My leave him alone.
I live with
defense mechanism.
He,
uh,
he definitely,
he went in there.
Gene.
Yeah.
Good for him.
But we can't tell
our kid not to or kids.
Oh,
I think I should some minor.
That liquids rewarding feeling from it though.
It's so gratifying.
Scratch your ears with the car keys.
No,
almost.
If I had to pick between that and Orgasms,
I would probably,
I would probably go the key.
You're not afraid of bacteria being introduced into the ear canal.
Look where we're putting our fingers in her mouth.
Yeah.
Every established already in the show.
Have you ever,
Paul's,
are you free to getting back to,
have you ever called a long hair out of your butt hole along here?
Have you ever?
Never.
No,
of course.
Yeah,
It's so special.
That one's very special way it happens.
Rarely was in body and I don't know how either you pull it out or it gets,
then you must be in your pool.
What is this here that falls and every once in a while it's like in your
underwear.
You see,
cause you're,
somebody just made a joke about having a long hair that they're pulling out of
it.
I remember wiping my ass and time and be like,
how did this fucking three foot hair and up in here?
It's definitely from just hair collecting coming around.
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
It's like now it's like in the Zeitgeists or just
before it starts.
Yeah.
See where this is going.
So awesome.
That was the best thing I've ever seen.
Say that again.
I mean for the listeners,
it's somebody had just the chocolate fountain idea first,
right?
We're not going to put a doll to show the repercussions.
At least three people put this idea together.
For the listeners who don't have,
who are in their shame pain in the background.
This is a party,
man.
I didn't realize that there's people watching.
This is like a New Year's Eve.
Look at the people over there.
There's people there.
I did not see where is this a child's party?
Is there like games on the,
Oh yeah.
This could be a birthday party.
I didn't even realize that.
Whoa,
whoa.
Is it only slow motion?
It could
be made into a Gif.
Please have this try.
This is great
for people listening.
There's a guy farting into a chocolate fountain and the chocolate is sprayed
over a baby doll space.
Good.
Ask One last time is done with the chocolate fountain.
All right,
we're going to be doing a thing,
but you're not going to want to use the chocolate.
Has everybody gotten their fill
out?
One more time.
Blue Dan,
please.
All right.
Here we go,
man.
That's a monster fart.
Yeah.
That was really,
it was a real farm.
And now you understand why we make the big bucks right
now.
You understand you own a home,
you own property,
but you wouldn't believe we've been fired from to corporate sponsors.
Make Morton's steakhouse.
Morton's gave you the boot Martins game.
Mcdonald's took away a lot of money.
Something like that.
Then you legit was,
those were real spots.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
you know what happened with Mcdonald's,
I don't know if you can get Terry Mcdonald's is somebody at first make it
Mcdonald's.
Like we should sponsor this without ever watching a single.
Yeah.
But what happened was the first episode that they sponsored had a um,
basically kind of a groundbreaking,
um,
like an immediately immediate classic clip we thought.
And that was the clip that they were like,
we are not into your show.
And you know,
the person that got the sponsorship got fired too from the air force.
You want to get to the kids.
It's like you get to the kids.
This was the clip.
Okay,
well let's see.
Hi there guys.
It's Pete again and I'm here to do a little video.
I wanted to use this but by greeny toy that I bought this new one and I thought
I'd try that again.
And then I also wanted to try this step one did fuck sleep that has these like
massive bullets in him.
I haven't used it of course.
And then I went to look and they didn't send any better.
He so bad that I'm not going to be able to use the vibrating park cause he does
work in it right now.
I'm sure that's going to get me off.
He's a loose cannon
Cochran,
two bikes,
doors,
man.
He lives with somebody.
Oh that's possible.
Yeah.
A friend of mine had one boyfriend,
double ended dude.
So I really want to try this because I like fucking stuff.
Yeah.
At first I'm going to try and get this in my butt and then turn it out and it's
even this cool little cool.
That's cool.
It's got a nice texture to it and it's also cools your indigenous art in the
background.
Shame are you bring those right here.
So
Mcdonald's side is this
they,
they were citing his hand movement,
which I was like,
I think he's his leg itches and they were like,
no,
it doesn't.
If he's like Mcdonald's went through this framework,
well they call it,
it's this moment that God,
I swear the s and p g with,
they were like,
what the hell?
First off,
he swears a couple times also he's jamming things in his asshole.
Is it off brand?
It's a little off.
Go ahead.
Real Chicago.
Johnny Milwaukee here.
Try not butt plugs.
It's got an ace cackling wraps around and goes up your ass.
Feels pretty good.
You Julian made in the USA so that's got that going forward to be proud of.
Yeah.
Oh,
the eye contact.
He's like looking off
but toy Bendigo
before we play
the slow driver.
Shit
go too fast.
Don't go too fast and a little hurt to try it again.
And Trust me,
once you get used to it
and relax yourself,
but play can be a lot of fun to get the car for now.
It feels pretty comfortable in there.
It,
it
is a tan line.
Yeah.
This is what killed us in the end.
And you're turning down,
turning down,
and it just cycles through the steps,
so,
oh,
that's just a constant.
Yeah.
Well that's even higher.
That's like a throbbing.
Yeah.
Uh,
but then are go ahead and jump to the,
I got it.
Thanks.
Opening.
This is what ended it here.
Alright.
Wow.
Well that's pretty tight.
I wasn't expecting that.
Oh,
fuck it.
Oh fuck,
fuck,
fuck.
Ah,
AH,
dammit.
Ooh,
look at his age.
Dammit.
There you go.
And then Mcdonald's was like,
no.
Yeah,
that's a chimp two point $3 million.
Was that,
was that real?
That does two points.
Two point $3 million.
We lost because of that.
Well,
yeah.
Oh,
I'm fixing it.
I'm you and you don't worry.
Okay.
All right.
Was it worth it?
Uh,
no,
no.
But you know what?
The show has integrity and
we keep it real on this show.
We honor the listeners.
2.3 2.3 hours for that.
But this guy's gonna cram a thing up his ass.
You fucking idiot.
Now what do you think that broke and Morton Straw.
What was the play that clip enough?
No.
Yeah,
Morton's was just like a,
you know,
they,
they gave us some money and then they,
they $2,000.
No,
all those are the more,
but that was for the paint job,
but then they were doing a little other stuff and then they just said,
we're not fitting the brand objective.
How did,
how do they get past the first step?
I don't know.
It's just complete ignorance.
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
I'd love some of that ignorance to throw some money my way.
Did you get any of the Mcdonald's money or was it all well,
no,
we had to give it back.
I know.
And Tom had purchased it or did you get,
did you get well,
I ordered a Lamborghini.
It's touted stupid.
So dumb.
You ordered a Lamborghini?
Yeah,
but I had to cancel the order with Mcdonald's money.
But you lost it because of the clip of the guys.
Fuck sock hurting him.
Yeah.
It wasn't even,
he came too fast.
It wasn't,
was that what it was?
I thought he was getting hurt.
You know,
he came,
came,
oh I thought it was hurting his dick.
No,
no.
He had an orgasm and he's like,
oh fuck.
And then he,
yeah.
Oh I thought he was clearly being electrocuted.
Mild.
No,
that would have been different if you a wish.
I hate if you wanted to hear it in slow motion here.
No.
Is any of this real,
why is your life,
what are your lives now?
There's,
yeah.
Did you tell them at the Lamborghini dealership why you had to cancel the order?
Um,
uh,
I didn't get into the actual details.
I feel if there's ever a time to get into the details
cause I was like,
I told her,
I was like,
I should get like some crazy exotic car just for fun.
And then no,
for practical reasons.
And,
uh,
this was before the Mcdonald's.
She was like,
that's stupid.
And then when the Mcdonald's money came through,
it just felt like it was gravy.
So then I was like,
no,
it's fine.
Right?
Cause like I guess so then I ordered it but now I'm going to get some jewelry.
Right.
We're going to do that.
I don't know Tom.
I think we should press pause on edge.
The jewelry.
He wants to get chains,
gold chains for his 40th birthday.
I know Kyle will support this idea.
Both asshole.
But you're doing it right.
God change.
I'm sure your heart's broken,
but that guy fuck away your Lamborghini money.
Let's say my name with disdain.
What do you like?
What,
what is,
what would be the soldier?
I don't even,
I,
I got seven remote control cars.
That's what I do for fun.
But I mean like,
like right now Mcdonald's calls you up and they go,
hey,
we heard you on.
Thanks for speaking some sensors,
3 million,
whatever you do.
Like keep stuff out of the buttons for two point $3 million.
Well we didn't even get that warning.
Yeah.
They told us a gym maybe infer that McDonald's wouldn't go for
a they,
they're like Mcdonald and what their offer was before 2.3 250,000.
Ha.
I Dunno.
That's how stupid.
This is crazy.
I was like,
no,
I don't want to do it.
I won't have Mcdonald's need more.
All right here,
watch this.
Wait for like a month.
Well,
if Mcdonald's is listening now,
just like if you got any of that 2.3 million,
I'll take like,
oh I don't,
I don't have,
I don't know what I'd want to do.
I don't know.
I think I,
but I don't,
I can't even think of it.
Like,
are you at that point that either of you grow up with money?
No.
Yeah,
a little bit.
A little bit.
But to think like,
oh,
just,
I can't even put myself in headspace.
Like I'm fine now,
but it just sitting in the bank cause I'm like,
this isn't a real thing what I do.
So the money doesn't feel,
it feels like,
it's like,
like a mob thing.
Like you robbed a bank,
like don't spend it.
People know.
Yeah.
But you don't enjoy it,
you know?
I know.
I'm not trying to be humble.
It's like there's nothing.
I know I feel the same.
There's nothing I have like given this stuff I do have that's like I suck at
guitar,
but I,
I bought some guitars that are nice and I like looking at it as fun.
Then that's it.
Like,
Oh this is a cool guitar and then I play it and like put it down.
You're not,
don't embarrass yourself.
I got some good mountain bikes that I got a big jeep with monster truck tires.
That's a dumb thing.
But I do this shit with it.
I go bang it up in a desert and everything.
That's cool.
So yeah,
just go.
I was wanting to know when you get something like that,
like how do you know where to go?
There's like there's a OHV spots like off road,
off highway vehicles,
spots out in like Gorman's one but I'll go to Anza Borrego down south.
I've been to Utah with,
it had been a Denver with it.
Let's put some miles on it.
Just just being out out in the world,
sitting out in a camping and shitting and shitting in the ground,
that chiefs like good shit in the ground without any legal ramifications.
That is good.
But like I don't like,
I don't,
but I didn't buy a house or anything.
Like I could buy a house,
but I'm like,
pardon me?
Likes that I could do comedy without knowing there's nothing they can take away
from me if I stopped doing comedy,
like I don't know the bank,
anything.
I know I owe no money,
so if I'm like,
you know what I want,
I don't want to do anything for a year,
I can do that without worrying about,
so maybe that's what I bought his freedom.
Yeah,
that's huge.
But doing anything,
I'm going to take a year off.
I sit on the couch,
watch binge watch the Americans.
That's all I'm doing.
I'm not doing it.
That's good though because when you're,
I mean that's,
what have you taken?
Did you take this past year off those fine?
No,
I didn't.
I left.
I'll take like a month off here and there.
That's going to go drive around and fuck off.
That's dependent on the ladies work schedule.
All December.
We were traveling and everything.
You wouldn't have be,
well,
that was a couple.
That was two years ago.
I was doing my show.
And then you announced,
you're shown the guide book and my show.
He's like,
well,
don't worry about it.
That Tom show is going to be real good too,
but we'll get a couple people.
We'll get a couple of people please,
please.
Okay.
I want to go back to the Lamborghini.
Yeah.
Orange.
It's embarrassing.
What is your car?
I don't give a fuck about cars.
No.
What is your car right now?
Okay.
Yeah.
Jeep jeep.
Like wrangler.
You have a jeep grand Cherokee.
The Porsche,
yeah.
Yeah,
but do you have another car too?
What's the other car?
It's a beamer.
Yeah.
And I got another card here.
What's the other car?
It's for the family.
What's the for the ambulance.
An escalate
and I got another one.
You got four?
Yeah.
Well I got five.
I don't feel bad about this Lamborghini thing fallen through.
Yeah.
I hope you have no money for your children's.
Can you make her worry?
No,
we're going to get that new steakhouse sponsor anymore.
Nice.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Hey,
by the way,
I put 20 bucks in the kids' college fund life lesson.
We got norms coming through a free meals for us and the kids whenever we need
them.
That's the sponsorship we got.
And I will say Morton's,
we didn't get free food.
Mcdonald's gave us free.
Yeah.
Morton's,
they only gave us employee discount.
So that was the drink three drinks.
You Bury barium anyway.
Yeah.
So yeah,
I still eat there.
Pay Full price.
What do you think I should ask for money wise from the next sponsor?
My head.
Don't talk to me about this shit.
I just want to get your yeah,
well show them that clip first
and then work on a realistic amount.
Like you realize your money's going to be behind this.
Right?
And that way they're not pulling it out for Monday.
Yeah.
Like all right here.
Show your,
show your cards.
How He's thinking.
Yeah.
Okay.
Show your cards.
Do.
This is such a good idea to talk about this show.
Now I'm going to be like,
Hey,
what I'll do is I'll give the agents,
I'll be like,
hey,
open the co open dialog with this clip.
So to hear Canadian,
the buried your mom's house when he was on it lost all funding.
Meanwhile,
I'm over here doing $50 Adam and eve spots for my podcast.
What is your pocket?
Everything that guy put on his dick.
Just plugging discount codes for that.
Wait,
I want to feel like that guy.
You want to come that fast?
Enter code boogie monster over at Adam and Eve took,
I'm doing free spots now.
Tele.
Tell me the podcast.
Boogie Monster.
Yeah.
And it's you and Dave guys.
If you think this podcast is stupid,
you should check out the boogie monster with cow Canadian and Dave Stone.
There you go.
You guys are doing it a while.
Yeah,
a couple of years.
It's just,
it's just us goofing off as a way to like plug babes and everything.
Yeah,
it's perfect.
Yeah.
We screw off.
I don't have the multimedia functions.
Yeah.
So we can,
we can react to watching shit videos on our phones,
but then nobody else knows what's going on.
Right.
Which isn't for good listening,
but like think about how great that Chocolate Fountain Fart was.
You know,
smell.
I'm seeing like the appeal of a multimedia.
Yeah.
That was the best moment of my life.
Hot for fun.
That was really hard.
Yeah.
Car Fine.
Yeah,
it was.
It was great.
She wasn't even open yet.
No,
I know.
I mean if there was a reason to celebrate
how disgusting is a chocolate?
I,
let's think about it from a hygienic perspective.
Like you're dipping in your food and then your fingers are in it and then the
chocolate just gets recycled.
Right.
Like a fountain.
It's nasty already a chocolate fan.
It's nasty.
Yeah.
That's what the guy with his assets was.
This thing's nasty already.
Why on the child's face y'all eat none of this gross
man.
That is awesome.
We got to do that for our kids birthday.
Can I hire this guy for
a kid at the party?
Let me see your
why
you're already sticky.
If you look at the baby's expression now too.
It kind of really
Chicago accent.
What am I saying?
Let's say you could try me.
Fatso you could try me.
Fatso yeah,
for the board.
It's Casino Casino will be here tomorrow was like,
you fucking try me.
Fatso and then he pulls his pants up.
Where's that as I want.
He's like beaten up don Rickles.
No,
it's a,
it's when he goes over to Sam's house.
Deniro.
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
He's like,
I'm going to come there tomorrow.
I'm going to get my fucking money.
You can't talk to me like that.
It's like,
nevermind Sam.
We'll come back.
Can I go to jail?
Cause I'm stupid.
Yeah.
So fun.
She up to,
is he all right?
He's in that movie.
He's in that new movie.
They're doing Scorsese.
He's doing another movie about Jimmy Hoffa and he's got a part in.
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
of course.
Mr Canadian.
It was so fun having you.
Will you tell me where can people see?
Do you have any dates lined up or anything coming up?
Royal Oak,
Michigan at the end of the month.
I think I'm not good with the website.
It's my name.
Kyle.
That's a good one,
right?
Yeah.
I got all the dates up there.
Okay.
I do podcast stuff.
Sure.
Yeah.
Put it in the graphic guys.
Do Graphics.
You,
do you do the Twitter up their twitters
or am I just doing this?
Yeah,
there's a good graphic.
Throw his phone number up.
I'll give it to you.
Social Security.
No,
thanks for coming,
man.
I'm glad we finally get this fun.
Yeah,
it was a lot of fun.
Can we play out with the chocolate part one more time?
Can I didn't know where to look the first time I would look at the fountain or
the,
but I want to look at the baby this time.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
go ahead.
That is stupid.
That was a mistake to look at.
The baby's face.
That dead.
I'd stare of a child's toy being desecrated.
Powerful.
That far it is.
If that bottom layer of the fountain has still has a hole in it,
look at that.
Look at the power of this park that's two layers of a chocolate fountain.
He no,
you're right.
That's not your habits as far as like he was one,
never seen something like it's a good for the obsec the exception of the baby
powder thing with the farts.
Right.
Never seen how far would impact.
Yeah.
So this is my first reference for something.
I mean,
look at how good he's doing right now.
I mean that's good work.
That's a multilayer fart top and bottom there.
I liked seeing the,
uh,
the heat sensor farts when someone's parts and on for red.
I would love to see like what that like I would do that and for myself,
I would want to know.
Yeah.
I fired up the car so bad they were today.
I thought I hit something.
It smelled like I ran over a possum or something.
It was bad.
It just stayed in the car.
Like I rolled down my own windows and how that show got worse.
Like I wasn't getting worse.
I feel like my farts are lingering more these days.
The older you get,
you're growing into being a dad.
Yeah.
In your farts are worse and your body's breaking down your poison.
You're turning down Melad death.
Death.
It is,
dude.
Check out this Ferrari.
I got in the back.
It's right back here when I burp the other day.
And you were like,
it was Korean food.
Oh,
that was the most disgusting thing ever.
We had a Korean,
you know ribs and Kelby.
Oh,
barbecue.
It's my fo and then she was like herb and burped and then she was like,
so am I going to,
I was like,
Holy Shit.
It actually smelled like she farted out of her mouth.
It didn't smell like a bird.
If I,
if I a barbecue and I burp and it's like,
this is just dead.
It's dead things.
Yeah.
It was like this smells like a cemetery.
Terrible.
And the garlic and they can't,
garlic is what set it over the top.
Yeah.
All right.
Check out my McLaren.
We're going to roll that out.
Thank you very much,
Kyle.
Thank you.
Same.
Right.
You know what I'm saying,
mom.
Mom,
you don't say
not in that same franchise.
You know what I'm saying?
What I'm saying?
The mayor.
You know what I'm saying?
Like this
same,
same like
some spot
light is
anyone understand?
Yeah?